uh claire coutinho
many other uh mps that have called out
boris johnson andrew bowie uh alicia
kearns lots and lots of mps who have
said today that they absolutely had
enough of this leadership gone in there
uh quite bullish really lots of laughter
from the committee room that they're
currently gathering in uh dominic guam
did turn up he didn't speak to us he
didn't answer any of our questions uh
stayed in the room and then left not too
long later so he's not there anymore as
far as we know
we still are waiting to find out what
the outcome of this meeting is going to
be whether uh the 1922 committee are
going to change those rules that may
allow them to have that second
confidence vote or not but what i'd say
so far is relatively a cheery tone from
a lot of the mps going into that
committee room and actually one back
bench mp uh walked past a group of
journalists in the corridor and said are
you ready to be lied to so i think and
and kind of laughed about it so i think
the tone is very much uh they've uh half
given up really on borrowings and uh and
all the lies they feel that they just
they can't stomach anymore
okay murray thanks very much and those
are live pictures you're seeing of the
windows of the meeting in the room in
which that meeting is taking place but
it uh sounds from what we're hearing
here in downing street from beth rigby
our political editor that uh it may be
uh done before that the number of
cabinet ministers uh uh pitching up here
to greet the prime minister seems to be
growing um what are you hearing beth
i've just heard or been told that pretty
patel the home secretary and uber
loyalist to boris johnson is also now in
number 10 so we saw anne-marie
trevallion go in we saw priti patel i'm
told is in there simon hart nadim zahawi
there's some rumors that michelle
donnelland that has just been made
education secretary is part of this
delegation uh brandon lewis and also as
we understand it michael gove uh was
also a cabinet minister earlier today
asking the prime minister to consider
his position that's seven mark that is
seven that i can count at this moment
there could be more that's on top of two
resignations of the chancellor and the
health secretary last night and the
resignation of oliver dowd and the party
chair after those by-election losses
when the prime minister was at choggham
in rwanda that's ten
cabinet ministers and that's what boris
johnson is coming back to face okay beth
stay with us and you can see in that top
right hand corner of your screen
government resignations 35 mps and is uh
it's been quite a torrid day for
the prime minister the former health
secretary sajid javid made a statement
uh in the commons today explaining the
reasons for his resignation
spreading the tightrope between loyalty
and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white olive friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue gray report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
sanji javid there a personal statement a
powerful personal statement in the
commons earlier beth was that the
um jeffrey howe moment uh you know
relating to when mrs thatcher had to go
i think
the real bombshell moment was actually
last night when sajid javid became the
first cabinet minister to go over the
top followed by rishi sanak it blew this
all open and since then uh the
snowballing of resignations has now
turned into an avalanche and cabinet
ministers that were supporting the prime
minister publicly last night and now
going into number 10 and saying to boris
johnson your time's up it's time to
stand down and if he doesn't do that
there's going to be the confidence vote
but if you lose
the support of your cabinet really as a
prime minister you lose all your power
you lose all your authority your
position does become untenable but if
you go back uh to that statement of
sacha javid i think it was two things
yes it was the jeffrey howe moment where
he was calling out the prime minister
made all the more potent i felt by the
fact it wasn't in anger it was almost in
regret and what he was also doing there
uh as you were mentioning or asking me
was it a job application yeah in the uh
sanjay javid what was he doing there he
was fleshing out his credentials his
backstory as a kid
from a deprived background
in which he didn't have any breaks he
didn't have the right school tie he went
into the city and he faced opposition
from bankers that didn't think that this
kid should be there and he climbed up
the ranks and he
was very clear to making that speech the
point that he was all about integrity he
said i didn't come into politics to be
somebody i came into politics to do
something uh so trying to really
was it a risk sorry to disturb your
train of thought but was it a risk being
first last night to resign and then
standing up today with the only personal
statement in the comments sometimes in
these moments mark no one wants to be
the person to wield the saw because the
person who wields the sword doesn't wear
the crown that's how it goes
so for weeks people have been saying
what will it take for cabinet ministers
to actually uh try to call time on this
rolling crisis of boris johnson's
government of recent weeks i think the
thing with sanji javid is he ran for the
leadership in 2019 he didn't get that
far but he made a good fist of it he no
doubt wants to try and run again but if
you ask mps realistically he wouldn't be
necessarily the front-runner
but by positioning himself in this way
he gets the profile he looks like he's
done the honorable thing in the eyes of
many colleagues
and then he
can build his own leadership bid or
indeed tack on to another leadership bid
if his
falls at some of the early stages which
is what happened last time when those
runners and riders in the end the mps
then decide to fall behind who they
think will win
we're jumping ahead a bit um just talk
about the logistics of the next
few moments because
boris johnson at the liaison committee
he's now coming back to downing street
and there are these cabinet ministers
waiting to see him so will we see will
he
rock up here in his car and walk in and
how will this expecting that he'll come
up in his car in fact there's some cars
coming up now and this this could be
uh the prime minister let's have a look
it is um
it's certainly it's an empty car
anyway uh so he will
waiting for him to come back he will
then go in and face this delegation
after that what happens i can't tell you
yet it might be that he comes out it
might be that he holds on he might say
no i want the confidence vote he might
take time to consider his options it's
real markets these things don't happen
very often it's really unclear about how
it's going to go
the last one i covered i guess
the case when i covered was was theresa
may
and what happened for theresa mo she
like boris johnson survived a confidence
vote she then went on for six months
until sir graham brady who was the chair
of the back bench
committee of the organizers the back
benches tapped her on the shoulder and
said if you don't resign we will force a
second confidence vote in you and at
that point she said it's better to
resign and organize an orderly
transition than be shoved out and and
you know margaret thatcher in the end
chose to resign and i guess what cabinet
are inviting boris johnson to do now is
take control of your departure
and and resign uh in order to avoid what
will be a very brutal uh battle but if
if you know if he loses the support of
seven eight nine ten cabinet ministers i
mean he's he's done that
he can't replace his situation this is a
bizarre situation where you had
nadim zahawi appointed last night as
chancellor
living here moves in and he's already
on his first day he's right because
he's already on his first stage
he's come in uh okay grant sharks is it
time up for boris johnson
grant do you want the prime minister to
stand down is that you come to tell him
to go sir
well stern faced well there you go so
we saw anne-marie trevelyan go in uh
when the prime minister stood at the
liaison committee i'm told pretty patel
is in there the chief whip is in there
i'm told nadeem zahawi that the
chancellor is joining that delegation
brandon lewis the northern ireland
secretary uh is part of that delegation
though he's physically in belfast and
then simon hart the welsh secretary so
boris johnson's going to have to face
these cabinet ministers when you're
retired
this will be it but you know he does
stick these things out but this doesn't
seem as though he can
go much further does it every time
we have asked the prime minister in
various trips with the groups of janus
or when i'm interviewing him
will you resign
what what circumstances would you resign
his he is
so consistent on this his view is i won
a mandate from the british people in
2019 14 million people voted for me i
won a majority of 80. that is where my
mandate lies mandate lies with the
public and i'm not going to be forced
out by recalcitrant mps or mps opposed
to me so he won't want to resign
my point with what's happening now is
whatever he wants this is entirely
beyond his control
and if his cabinet desert him his
position is simply not tenable but we'll
have to see how it plays out okay we'll
keep going on that
door behind us and uh we'll talk about
what happened a little earlier because
it's been an extraordinary
day a dramatic day and at prime
minister's questions uh this lunch time
boris johnson insisted that he planned
to as he put it hang on in there and
keep going
he then faced the chairs of all the
common select committees as we were
saying at the powerful liaison committee
in a session that lasted two hours or so
he said he couldn't see
why he should resign and when he was
questioned by uh labour's darren jones
he said this
it's not brave for you to carry on doing
this i think in my view you're hurting
the country prime minister
just on a very human level surely you
must know that
it's in the country's interest for you
to leave now isn't it i i look i i think
that the country is going through tough
times and i think that we have the
uh the biggest
you know you're making a a point about
about duty right yeah and uh i i look at
the uh the issues that this country
faces i look at the um
the pressures of people uh are under and
the need for government to focus on
on on their priorities uh which is what
we are doing i look at uh the biggest
war in europe for 80 years
and
i cannot for the life of me uh see or
how it is responsible just to to walk
away from that as i said earlier on in
in pmq's particularly not when you have
a mandate of the kind that
we won
two three years ago
i'm just hearing another pps has gone
peter gibson i think from the department
of trade he has
resigned so it's mounting up now let's
get some reaction from
the liaison committee member darren
jones who asked that question then of
boris johnson thank you for being with
us and uh it would appear that the game
is up
yes but the only person that doesn't
seem to know that is the prime minister
and as i um
told him during the committee there's a
delegation of his cabinet colleagues
waiting for him in downing street i
understand he's now back in downing
street and maybe he's going to start to
realize now that it's time for him to
leave
but he he doesn't seem to want to go he
does stick around i mean do you think
it's inevitable that he will go in the
coming hours
i think he has to i mean i just can't
see how he can carry on and as i put it
to him in the liaison committee
all of this political drama is
distracting the government from getting
on with the issues the country faces
people are deeply worried
about the autumn and winter ahead they
can't pay their energy bills as it is
they're going to go up again later this
year the cost of living crisis is a
problem for so many the economy is in a
mess we need a government that can deal
with those issues
it was an extraordinary performance in
some ways from boris johnson in the
liaison committee i mean this is a man
on the on the brink on the very edge of
of uh having to leave office and he was
just batting away questions about that
and was talking about other issues as if
it was perfectly normal and he was going
to be carrying on for months if not
years
the man is deluded i mean what can i say
i mean he was talking about convening a
roundtable on fertilizer supplies i mean
fertilizer supply is an important issue
for the country
but his government is falling apart
around him i hope that now when he sat
down in downing street with his cabinet
colleagues telling him his time is up
that he will realize and do the right
thing and resign
i mean it's not great for labor if he
goes is it doesn't it suit you better if
if he just staggers from one crisis to
another and stays in office
i mean sure but it's not good for the
country i mean as i've already mentioned
we've got enormous pressures facing us
now they're going to get worse as we get
towards the end of the year we need a
government that can focus on the issues
is in the interest of the country for
boris johnson to resign as prime
minister but as i put to him today is
not just his failure the conservative
party's failure over the last 12 years
taxes up debt up growth down paid down
it has been a decade of failure on the
economy and public services by the
conservatives
and so they should all be ashamed of
themselves
you said that he was delusional in his
uh performance at the liaison committee
what did the
tory members of that committee make of
it what was they what were they saying
afterwards
well they all look pretty gloomy to me
in the same way they all look pretty
gloomy during prime minister's questions
and
i think it was your news channel that
had the rolling figure of resignations
that we were looking at on our phones
during the session and they saw what was
coming um before them i think probably
all of the conservatives in the liaison
committee i think i probably shouldn't
speak to them but i think all of them
know that boris johnson's time is up and
he needs to go and they probably want to
get on with it as quickly as possible
just going back to
the issue of
when he goes or you know whether he goes
and what happens when he goes
a new leader
a new leader of the tory party a new
prime minister
will get a honeymoon period like most
new leaders do
and you know could start doing well in
the polls and could be a threat a bigger
threat than boris johnson
at
the next election
yeah look i don't think the labour party
should feel coward by that i mean the
bar that boris johnson has said is very
low but the conservatives record on the
economy and on public services over the
last decade speaks for itself i think
the british people want a change in
government a government that's going to
get on with those
fixing those issues for people and pay
on public services
and on the economy and people's living
standards and the labour party should be
very confident it is very confident
about taking that message to the british
people whenever the next election comes
and what about your own leader uh sakia
stama i mean
if boris johnson clings on somehow
he may well have to go if durham police
decide that he broke the law
yeah i mean it's a hypothetical question
um i hope that darren police will
quickly uh announce the outcome we're
all very confident that kirsten will not
be fined because he didn't break the law
we can then draw a line under it and be
focused on the election
and is your leader making the kind of
impression that he should be with the
tory party in utter disarray
yes
remember that only two years ago in 2019
the labour party was nearly
decimated it was nearly killed in that
general election our worst electoral
defeat since the 1930s
kirsten has managed to turn around the
labour party at great speed over the
course of the last two years and the
polling shows that on economic
competence on preference for prime
minister and their ability to lead um on
on support for public services and so on
and so forth kirstarma and rachel reeves
of our shadow chancellor are performing
very well in the eyes of the public and
that's why i say we will be confident in
going to the british people with our
offer to them if an election is called
either in the next few weeks or in the
next two years
okay and just finally how do you think
this will play out what is your hunch
look i don't know i mean part of me
assumes that boris johnson is not a man
that will stand outside downing street
and resign uh we've just heard the 1922
committee has not changed the rules to
trigger another
vote of no confidence early what does
that mean it means that either the prime
minister could call an election um and
take it to the british people um or
conservative mps are going to once again
fail to get rid of him and continue to
prop up his political vandalism for
longer than needs to be to the detriment
of the country and the british people
okay darren jones thank you very much uh
indeed and we were talking there about
zakir starman let's take a closer look
now what happened in the commons today
at prime minister's questions boris
johnson's future dominated exchanges of
course with uh sakira stama our
political correspondent ali fortescue
analyzes what happened in pmq's
unwrapped
it was an extraordinary pmq's mps waited
some wondered if he'd even show up but
as the prime minister arrived to a
solemn front bench eddie cheers were
very quickly drowned out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the chamber was silent as he asked
his first question relaying the details
of an alleged assault by chris pincher
he says
he grabbed my ass and then he slowly
moved his hand down in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister
just how serious the situation is
the pm tried to rally his side focus on
policy but it wasn't working
not least the 500 000 people we got off
welfare into work in the last six months
alone mr speaker those are things that
are making differences to the lives of
people up and down the country and i'm
proud of it
no one's cheering
labor unimpressed but look at the pm's
own side their faces said it all
what a pathetic spectacle the the dying
act of his political career is to parrot
that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
and if we look more closely at what was
going on on the tory benches sachit
javid arrived late to support from
rebels like mark harper but avoiding eye
contact with his old cabinet colleagues
missing from the front bench today was
housing secretary michael gove no word
yet on his position the mood though was
glum
this was pmq's in january jonathan
gullis cheering on the prime minister at
the height of partygate but look at him
today after resigning his junior role in
government last night elsewhere tory
backbenchers used the opportunity to
have their say
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
resign today i ask him to do the
honorable thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
nothing
left for him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
the prime minister's response here to
labour's ian lavery perhaps sums up the
tone hang on in there mr speaker that's
what i'm going to do
and after pmq's came the scathing
statement from sajid javid who left the
chamber to pats on the back boris
johnson though couldn't have exited much
more quickly labour keen to bid him
farewell
[Music]
kirstama had a good pmqs but it was an
easy day to be leader of the opposition
mps behind the prime minister who
cheered him on through thick and thin
was solemn today the teflon prime
minister losing a grip on his own side
well that was then this is now and
things are moving incredibly quickly and
beth it's fair to say that boris johnson
is in deep deep trouble tonight
he is mark we are waiting for him to
come back to number 10 after the liaison
it might be that he's uh in the commons
in his office there talking to mps
taking advice what we do know is that
his chief whip chris heaton harris is in
number 10 and a number of cabinet
ministers have formed a delegation to
gently tell boris johnson that it's time
for him to resign
who are they we know it's simon hart the
welsh secretary nadim zahawi the
chancellor there are reports that
michelle donald who's just been
appointed education secretary is also
part of that group we've got brandon
lewis the northern ireland secretary
over in belfast at the moment but coming
back grant shaps we just saw walk in
didn't we didn't very stoney-faced and
marie trevelyan also just went in and
i've been told although we didn't see
her that the home secretary priti patel
is also in number 10 so
boris johnson at pmq's today at the
liaison committee state insisting that
he is going to fight on that he's been
given that mandate from the british
people to govern the country that he
doesn't see the necessity
for any election that he is the man in
power and a number of his cabinet saying
now
no it's time for you to go and at this
point of proceedings
it's hard to see how he can cling on if
he has
10 11 of his cabinet ministers either
resigned or about to if he doesn't do
what they would say is the honourable
thing and fall on his sword precisely
and
i was about to say before grant chaps
distracted us walking in very stony
faced as you say
extraordinary not even
you know appointed chancellor
and within 24 hours he's telling boris
johnson we assume he's one of part of
the party telling boris johnson to go
you can look at that in two ways i mean
one of his supporters and i said lizzie
the nadeem zahawi is in the delegation
given that he's just been promoted
this person's view was if the prime
minister asks you to serve the country
cannot be without a chancellor so of
course he stepped up to the job other
people would say it's a machiavellian
move and he took that position only to
decide to ask the prime minister uh the
following day with a group of other
cabinet ministers now nadim zahawi would
be considered a real runner and rider
now to replace boris johnson so nadim
zahawi
now
leading if you like a delegation to tell
him to go it's interesting mark because
i spoke to a very senior former cabinet
minister last night
and this person is an old sage if you
like been around a lot seen a lot and i
said what do you think and they said to
me
boris johnson's finished and then they
said and so is nadeem because nadeem had
taken this position and maybe nadeem
overnight nadim sahawi had taken a view
that actually it was more damaging to
try and prop up a fatally wounded prime
minister
than to actually be part of a delegation
world in the act that
former cabinet minister also said to me
last night when i said how long has he
got this person said
i'd give him days at the time i thought
i think it could take longer than that
because the cabinet was supporting him
and we knew boris johnson wanted to
fight on so then we would turn into
would the 22 change the rules to force
the vote but goodness me events have
moved very very quickly since then i
think we've had now 36 resignations from
cabinet when i was doing a live here at
10 p.m last night we'd had nine that's
how quickly things have moved today
now you
know him reasonably well what is it
about what is it about boris johnson
that makes him so reluctant
to go so
unwilling to to sort of read the room on
this
i think the first thing is
and i don't try and interpret my i i
kind of listen to what how he answers
questions and what people around him
that know far better than i would say
i think genuinely he is of the view that
he uh
won an election with a huge mandate the
biggest conservative majority the most
successful election winner since
margaret thatcher who served for a
number of years as conservative prime
minister and i think he is of the view
that he has got a mandate from the
people
14 million of them that voted for him
and he's not going to be booted out by a
bunch of mps that no longer want him
in power and i think also there is a
sort of sense in number 10 too that some
of these rounds are about running the
old arguments of brexit versus uh
staying in the eu with the levers versus
the remainers that there is still bad
blood between boris johnson that one of
the party but what's so terrifying for
him when he surveys the landscape today
is that the
disquiet and the desire for him to go
goes across all wings of the party and
most worryingly earlier today i mean you
had people like lee anderson and
jonathan gullis i mean they were
jaw-dropping to me mark because these
were mps that were die-hard lawyers you
would even off record even in private
conversations they would never say
anything critical about the prime
minister and for them to actually come
out and say the game's up and he's lost
support everywhere
and the one thing he was clinging on to
last night was those cabinet ministers
coming out after rishi sanak as sajid
javid resigned saying we still supported
him and now he's lost that
there's nowhere else for him to go
and he says as you say that you know i
was put in here by the voters huge
majority what was 80 seats or so
is there any chance that he could go
to the country again i mean i did notice
to be honest in the liaison committee
that he kind of ruled it out
so so that was the that was something we
asked jacob brie smog dermott and i were
interviewing jacob rees-mogg last night
uh shortly
uh
yeah last night about seven o'clock and
and we asked jacob uh rhys smog shortly
after those rested nations this very
question he didn't rule it out but
you're right what was interesting in the
liaison committee is the prime minister
did and you could see a scenario where
he says i'm not going to allow you to
vote yeah i'm going to call a snap
election but i think any kind of attempt
to do that you need a base you need some
support in the parliamentary party and
that has uh sorry in your government and
cabinet and that has that has drained
away and he did as you noted in the
liaison committee
let's just look at this that was cabinet
yesterday
the faces were absolutely
and i look at cabinet pictures every
week as we put them together in our tv
reports and it was absolutely miserable
there's nadine dory's one of his arch
supporters just face forward she looks
really unhappy jacob rees-mogg looking
very somber there sawela braverman the
attorney general chris heaton
thoughts of michael gates that's the
chief
whipper michael gove just looked
absolutely what's michael goes position
is is he in there so michael gave wasn't
at pmq's and this set the hair running
about whether or not michael gave was
going to resign and last night people
because he didn't immediately uh
show any sign of support so people were
wondering about michael gove last night
until his team said no he's staying on i
was told earlier that he had been in
pmq's prep with the prime minister this
morning but then it subsequently emerged
and we stood up
that michael gove had privately said to
the prime minister i think really you
should
resign um
and i think the unspoken uh
calculation in that for michael gove was
and if you don't maybe i would consider
my position but you have to remember
michael gove wielded the sword in 2016
when he stood against boris johnson in
the leadership and both men then
withdrew from the race and theresa may
became the prime minister he then stood
against boris johnson in 2019 and i
think maybe at this moment in time
michael gove might not want to be
the operator that wields the knife so
he's definitely in the scene behind
you know behind closed doors
it's been a it's been a lifetime a
lifetime of politics hey well listen um
it does appear that uh boris johnson's
fate may well be being decided in
downing street in the coming hour or two
but uh there is this other meeting going
on of the mps the 1922 committee uh the
organization representing tory back
benchers in the commons uh they are
meeting
now and our political correspondent uh
mari aurora is there and joins me on the
phone so what is happening there mari
hi yeah so uh we know that the 1922
community have not yet changed their
rules although they have brought four of
their executive elections so now the
nominations are open the vote will take
place monday afternoon the vote will be
counted monday evening and then once
that's been finished then they can
potentially discuss uh changing the
rules to be able to hold that second
confidence vote for boris johnson one mp
i spoke to who said uh they changed
those uh they moved up that nomination
essentially so that number ten can't say
that they didn't have the mandate
we've got another cavalry dory secretary
of state is it time for boris johnson to
resign
nadine doris is it time for boris
johnson to resign
do you still support the prime minister
nadine doris is it time for him to go
so nadine doris
is in i mean how significant is that
obviously a enthusiastic supporter of
the prime minister
i
i'm surprised i would be surprised to
see her in a delegation of cabinet
ministers telling him to go the reason i
think she might be if that is indeed why
she has gone in is because
she cares deeply for boris jones they
are actually very very good friends i
think and i remember when boris johnson
pulled out of the race in 2016. nadine
doris at the end of that speech when
they thought he was going to announce
his candidacy only to say he had decided
not to i remember that she was in tears
she was so upset
and and
she has supported him
so loyally the whole way through
so it might be that she is in there
because
she wants to say to him
your time's up i don't know well but
she's in she had the look of a cabinet
minister who was resigned to uh this
government's fate didn't she
she did not look and and sometimes she
would stop and say a few words but not
today okay uh beth stay with us and uh
keep her an eye on an ear out let's
speak now to the conservative mp andrew
morrison who was uh i think the third mp
to resign last night stepping down as a
trade envoy thank you very much for
being with us and it does appear that uh
pretty soon the game may be up
yes thank you for having me on i believe
the game is up and i think it's
important that boris johnson
needs to he needs to leave in a decorous
fashion he needs to leave with some
vestige of dignity now and i hope very
much that my senior colleagues are
speaking to him as we speak to say look
boris this isn't going anywhere and you
can either leave with dignity uh which
is your due
or you leave in an unseemly scrap which
i fear uh is really what he has been
intent on up to this point
yeah you see
you said in your letter last night that
uh what was it your position has become
unrecoverable and it's been quite clear
through the day today uh today that he
doesn't agree with that yeah i know he's
he's a political leader like no other in
our history any other leader would have
gone way before now but boris keeps
hanging on but there comes a point where
that's simply not sustainable and i
think we're beyond that point now
he will go the question is when and in
what manner and i i sincerely hope he
goes in a dignified fashion goes goes
now rather than drag this out which
isn't in his interest it's not in the
interest of the party we both serve and
it's certainly not in the interest of
the country
and is it your understanding that these
cabinet ministers here in downing street
are here to tell him to go
i hope so i've been in touch with a
number of senior colleagues in the
course of the day uh just trying to
persuade them to use their wise counsel
with the prime minister so we we bring
this to a conclusion now you know enough
is enough has to end it has to end now
and the extraordinary thing
about uh this and this prime minister is
he has brought all this
essentially on himself
yes but you know many of the
faults and character issues that have
brought him to this place are precisely
the ones that we uh felt were necessary
in order to get the job done when we
supported him back in 2016 and 2019
at that time of course we had to deal
with brexit we had to get it through and
it was proving impossible and it seemed
to many of us at that time that a big
character like boris johnson was the
only way to resolve this and he's
achieved that he's done that but here we
are two years later and and those
characteristics and those faults and
foibles uh those errors of character i'm
afraid of coming home to roost and we
can't go on like this
yes you also knew uh at the time that he
you knew his character pretty well you
knew that he was a man who
actually put it plays fast and loose
with the truth you knew all that and yet
you still
um
made him prime minister
well i think uh
the circumstances at the time were were
very pressing i don't think we truly
knew the extent of what we were letting
ourselves in for if i could put it in
those terms that's been played out over
time
but i think now you know those of us who
have resigned had to
face the equilibrium between loyalty
which we all feel of course to him
particularly those of us who supported
him in the past and the need to preserve
integrity and decency and honesty and
make sure that our party a great party
in our political history
remains recoverable and at the moment if
this drags on for any longer i think
that is seriously called into doubt so
this has to be dealt with has to be
dealt with now either by senior
ministerial colleagues or by the 1922
committee
is it the truth though that many tory
mps are simply now worried about their
seats
well inevitably we all face the
electorate that's the whole point of our
democracy isn't it we're answerable to
them and certainly i've been left in no
doubt by mine and by
the electorate in somerset where i was
campaigning during the local government
elections in may and in the tiverton and
holland by-election
more recently
the strength of feeling on the doorstep
and people were very polite they're very
nice and they said look we're
conservative voters we'll vote for you
next time but we're not going to vote
for you this time because of your leader
and andrew what was it for you that
made you decide to resign
well the straw that broke the camel's
back for me personally uh was lord
mcdonald's letter to the parliamentary
commissioner for standards yesterday i
know lord macdonald from his time at the
foreign office where i was a minister
he's a man of complete and unimpeachable
repute so it was a question of whether
he was telling the truth or whether the
prime minister was telling the truth and
for me uh there is no question about
which one was telling the truth so that
made explicit what a lot of us knew all
along about the character of the prime
minister
and that is finally
what
made my mind up in terms of the timing
of my resignation
and just finally
what do you see happening in the coming
hours what do you what do you hope
happens in the coming hours
well this is moving extremely fast and
the government is collapsing like a pack
of dominoes i don't think the prime
minister will be able to fill the
slots that have been left by departing
ministers and i expect more resignations
later on uh today that's just not a
sustainable position you have to keep
government going somehow or another and
if you don't have credible candidates to
fill those slots what on earth are you
to do i just hope that cabinet ministers
in particular who must know that this is
end game uh press upon the prime
minister this evening that this is game
over and he must go now
andrew morrison thank you very much
indeed straight back to that meeting of
the
22 committee which i'm told is breaking
up murray aurora is there joins me now
um what is happening
yes so uh most of those mts now just
filed out of the room uh all together um
i would say some sombra looks uh some
kind of hands tied behind their backs
slowly uh walking away so i wouldn't say
it was as cheery as the tone uh perhaps
when they went in uh however not as
gloomy as perhaps it could be
we know that they have not uh changed
the rules of the 1922 committee yet
they have brought forward that um vote
for the executive
so now we know the vote will take place
on monday afternoon and then the results
monday evening and if they do they wish
to change those rules that would then
take place perhaps monday evening after
the vote results are announced um now we
know uh that also i saw sajid javad
leaving about five minutes ago uh with
sake bhatti who was a pps who also
resigned uh last night as well as sajid
javid uh he looked in very good spirits
uh dominique raja supposedly had spoken
about the bill of rights which seems
slightly uh ill informed at this time
another mp i was speaking to told me
that the reason they brought the vote
forward so that they could potentially
change the rules on monday night was so
that number 10 couldn't say that they
hadn't they didn't have the mandate of
colleagues to be able to change the
rules so uh backbenchers trying to kind
of cover their backs there and avoid any
kind of accusation of hypocrisy or any
kind of accusation of not having the
mandate to be able to uh carry on with
those rule changes um so yeah i would
say more of a sunburst home than perhaps
uh earlier when they were going in but
at the same time i wouldn't say it was
massively gloved
okay mari thanks very much indeed beth
rigby here in downing street so mari's
saying there that they're going to
hold the election before deciding on any
rule changes which is pretty
straightforward i guess but it's what
happens here
in the next few hours that could be the
deciding factor for the premiership of
boris johnson i think mark
it's moving so quickly now i i imagine
from the perspective of the executive of
the 1922 committee they are not now
thinking that their
confidence vote is necessarily the route
of deposing of boris johnson because
they can see what is happening in real
time with the cabinet and so they are
probably taking the decision well we
don't need to enact a rule change to try
and force a vote because they think
perhaps this will come to a natural
conclusion given what's going on in
number ten and nadine doris i missed it
because if she was right down there she
was asked as she walked up are you going
to call for him to quit she said
certainly not so nadine doris has gone
in there
as i said she's an ardent supporter of
the prime minister
going in there obviously
to back him up against other cabinet
ministers who are now waiting for him uh
to tell him uh that it's time to go i
can see some cars coming up i don't know
if this could be the prime minister i
can see some cars coming
but we know that there's a number of
cabinet ministers in there now
that are going to tell him that they
think it's time for him to go so
let's see how that plays out in the
coming hours the 22 there as mari was
saying has left themselves uh with this
so i'm just looking out see who's coming
next have left themselves with the
option there's grant shaps the transport
secretary part of the delegation but as
mari was saying sorry the num 22 have
left themselves with the option of
changing the rules early next week to
force a confidence vote
if necessary it's interesting when i was
speaking to andrew morrison i mean he
was saying
basically that the government is now
collapsing like domino's he said
well you've had 36 resignations i mean
that is a huge
chunk of your payroll staff 36
resignations and now we've got well we
were counting weren't we you know six
seven eight nine potentially ten cabinet
ministers uh that are withdrawing
support the government has collapsed it
is in the process
of collapsing and that for boris johnson
means if he can't
hold together a cabinet hold together a
government put enough ministers in and
aids into posts he simply can't run the
country he's got no option
but to resign
okay hold far just a second because i
think we can speak to roger gale a tory
mp who has been pretty clear
in the last few days and weeks that he
wants boris johnson out he was in the
1922 committee meeting and
i think can join us now and just give us
a sense of the
of the mood in that meeting what was
decided what was the tone
what i'd say is that the mood was
courteous
you would not expect me to divulge what
actually was said in the 1922 committee
it's a private meeting and i won't do it
but what i will say is that it was a
sadness to me
to find a number of colleagues who
yesterday were ministers who of course
are now back benches and were therefore
attending the 1922 committee
it's a huge sadness that
some very good very talented
young men and women have found it
necessary to resign and i think that
probably indicates the strength of the
problem that we're faced with and it's a
problem that won't be resolved until we
have a new prime minister
is it your understanding roger that the
cabinet ministers turning up here in
downing street will be telling the prime
minister to go
i have no idea what they're going to
tell the prime minister
but i would hope that the chief whip
would have spoken to the prime minister
i fear however that given the nature of
the man
it's likely that the 1922 committee will
have to change the rules and we will
have to have
a vote of no confidence it would be much
more dignified
for the prime minister and much kinder
actually for the prime minister and
indeed his wife
who we have to remember also
must be feeling some pain
if he were to
simply
understand the situation
and leave with dignity and quietly
so you think there's a possibility to
you that even if
cabinet ministers here
suggest to him that uh it's all over
that uh he should just leave office you
think he could quite possibly stay on
and wait for this whole process of mps
changing the rules of the committee and
having another vote of confidence you
think that could actually happen dude
i fear that is the nature of the man
that we're dealing with
he seems determined to cling on for as
long as he possibly can i don't think
that's dignified
i don't think it's a sensible way
forward he needs to consider first the
country
second his party and third those close
to him
if he does all of that then sensibly
he would resign
and clear the pathway for somebody else
to be elected
and to take over the government and to
take us forward at the moment there is a
huge division within the conservative
party
and
he unfortunately is the cause of that
division
but surely if his new chancellor uh the
transport secretary we're seeing there
now other cabinet ministers who have
arrived at downing street tell him to go
then even
even boris johnson will realize that
that's it
um mark let us hope that common sense
will prevail as you suggest
but if it doesn't then we're going to
have to take the hard road forward
so i mean the mps that were in that
committee there's no question in your
view that
there are enough to
in the new elections to have control
over changing the rules and have enough
mps who will then vote
you know to to change those rules
i think there is an overwhelming
majority now
of members of the parliamentary party
who believe that this is the end game we
have to have a change but it would be
quite wrong of me to suggest that there
aren't also
people even now
feel that mr johnson should remain in
office
that is where the division lies
okay roger gale thank you very much
indeed beth i mean extraordinary that
roger gail thinks that even if
senior cabinet ministers here
are really telling him now that his time
is up that uh you may still carry on and
may still
let this sort of mps 1922 process take
place and then the process will play out
i think
what is clear
mark is you only serve as the prime
minister not just
through the confidence of the public and
them giving you their vote but also
through the confidence and support of
your parliamentary party and your senior
colleagues politics can be brutal people
fight and argue and plot but essentially
a prime minister who has lost the
command of his cabinet his government
and his parliamentary party yeah he can
say half of my cabinet can leave i will
not step down but if that really happens
at that point the party will trigger a
confidence vote
how many cabinet ministers would have to
go
look
given how many people have resigned
today 36 then we've got the delegation
of cabinet ministers they're not even in
that count at the moment you think 148
mps already voted against boris johnson
in the first confidence vote uh the
numbers don't lie
you just have to add them up i mean
effectively if he can
if he tries to continue
it looks like uh they will have the
numbers
in terms of the cabinet the current
resignations the the stream of other
letters from mps today uh to force him
out right 30 seconds beth are people
just joining us what is happening inside
downing street right now what is
happening inside downer street now is a
delegation of cabinet ministers are
gathering to tell boris johnson
that his time is up and that he ought to
do what they would say is the honorable
thing and resign and they have gone as a
delegation
to tell him to go to ask him to fall on
his sword before the parliamentary party
take matters into their own hands and
try to force him out so beth thank you
very much indeed so it really does look
like the dying hours uh potentially for
boris johnson's premiership this is the
newshour on the sky news coming
up boris johnson is hanging on just as
prime minister but cabinet ministers are
arriving here at downing street to tell
him to go much more
at the top of the hour
[Music]
organism
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force forces
to get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the newshour live from downing
street i'm mark austin coming up
the game is up cabinet ministers arrive
in downing street to tell boris johnson
that he has to go but the prime minister
insists he's staying off
i'm not going to give her a running
commentary on political events and we're
going to get on with the government of
the country
36 conservative mps have now resigned
from the government saying they will no
longer stand by boris johnson
and the prime minister now faces the
prospect of another confidence vote at
the hands of his own mps
we'll bring you all the twists and turns
live as they happen on another dramatic
day in westminster
[Music]
good evening from downing street where
time appears to have run out for the
prime minister cabinet ministers are
waiting in the building behind me here
to tell boris johnson that he must now
stand down it follows the resignation of
36 members of his government in the last
24 hours despite the erosion of his
support the prime minister has remained
pretty bullish both prime minister's
questions
and before a committee of senior mps
it's being reported that there's a
delegation of your cabinet colleagues
waiting in downing street including the
chief whip the transport secretary and
your new chancellor
waiting to tell you when you finish here
today that it's time for you to go how
will you respond to that uh uh
darren you're you're asking me to
comment on this conversation it's been
in a few minutes
but i i if you want to ask about uh what
we're doing to help people uh with the
cost of living if you want to ask about
what we're doing to build more clean
green energy supply which uh this this
community has taken an interest in
that's going to be your answer to the
cabinet colleagues
i'm very happy to to talk to you about
it but i'm not going to give a a running
commentary on political events and we're
going to get on with the government of
the country
there we are boris johnson there
insisting pretty much all day that he's
going to carry on uh political editor
beth rigby is with me uh can he carry on
well mark we're in the end game now he
either
carries on for a few days and then gets
uh faces another confidence vote and
given the mood of the party the number
of resignations and the cabinet
desertions now uh it appears that that
would be a hard vote to win or he heeds
the advice of those cabinet ministers
gathering in number 10
uh this evening and he chooses uh to
stand down now where have we got to well
i can give you an update of who uh is in
there in terms of cabinet ministers that
we are sure have gone in to tell him to
resign we've got nadine zahawi uh the
new chancellor michelle donald who is
the new education secretary so she was
promoted she's in the delegation we've
got grant shaps the transport secretary
brandon lewis the northern ireland
secretary uh we've got kit mart house
the policing minister not not in cabinet
but but kit mart house is one of
boris johnson's key allies he were you
remember he worked with him
uh in london you have simon hart the
world champion also in there we have
anne marie trevelyan and we have the
home secretary pretty patel
the other person that came in but for
very different reasons tonight
was nadine doris now she is the culture
secretary she is one of boris johnson's
closest allies she has backed him to the
hilt
since the very beginning and she went in
there and she's gone in there to battle
for him so they are gathered in there i
imagine the atmosphere is pretty
unpleasant you can say with certainty
can you that that's what they are in
there to do
they are in there to tell him look it's
over and you've got to go now yes and
presumably he will heed that advice or
is that
a presumption too far
well that's a presumption too far
because we don't know what goes on
behind that door but what we do know is
that let's just focus on what we do know
and not speculate too much because this
could unfold very quickly and we don't
know how the promise is going to respond
but what we do know is that a sizable
chunk of his cabinet are now telling him
that it's time for him to resign so just
to be clear the people we definitely
know that we have spoken
to people on their teams or people close
to them who are definitely calling him
to go
are nadim zahawi
grant shapes brandon lewis simon hart
kit malthouse and
michelle donolon that's half a dozen
cabinet ministers two have already gone
and we also had uh
uh oliver letwe and sorry oliver dowden
uh resigning a week ago
so when's the last time almost an entire
cabinet i mean dominic raab is not there
he's fighting his case or was fighting
his case but when's the last time an
entire cabinet
this is this is the point about
convention with boris johnson and him
defying convention and doing things
differently he's a maverick he always
has i mean theresa may never got to this
point because graham brady came in the
chair of the 22 so that's being told
he's well i've heard that he might be
with the cabinet has he just walked into
the cabinet office he's just walked into
the cabinet somewhere yes okay number 70
whitehall so you tell me what what well
the reason i've been slightly uh looking
over your shoulder mark is not because
i'm looking at someone else apart from
you but i was looking to see if uh sir
graham brady was going to come up the
street because he was spotted walking
down here 70 that all that is is another
entrance 70 whitehall is another
entrance to downing street so you go
through the cabinet office so now we
know as well that sir gray and brady the
chair of the 22 committee is also
waiting for an audience
with the prime minister and i have no
doubt that he has gone in there
to relay to him the mood of the party so
they're all in there and now we're
waiting uh for boris johnson to come
back it might be that he has come back
by another entrance and we haven't seen
him uh but i think in the circumstances
he'd want to come in through the front
door so after months of all this
speculation and uh which is you know
there's been peaks and troughs he
quietens down when he goes abroad and
then he comes back for another domestic
crisis after months of all this this
could be
the night that uh boris johnson
is told that he has to go well it will
be the night he's told he has to go but
it could be the night he goes
last night when those two cabinet
resignations happened um sachin javid at
about 6 p.m and
and rishi said like a match of minutes
later
we all thought at that moment this is it
is this the beginning of the end is this
the dominoes and then what happened was
the cabinet shored him up um
but there was a question and and we
reported it last night could this be the
moment that the cartons come down that
after months of scandal and crises and
arguing and the confidence vote and
resignation letters
and disquiet and unhappiness was this
going to be the moment that finally
tipped the balance and it wasn't
entirely clear last night i came to the
conclusion last night that it had moved
from a question of can he survive to how
long he can survive but events have
moved incredibly quickly today as i was
saying last night when we were standing
here nine resignations there are now 36
so from overnight to now
27
of his
ministers ministerial aides members of
government have quit and then you've got
another group of cabinet ministers
threatening to do the same i mean
it really has snowballed it's become an
avalanche actually um
and
i think it's i think it is literally
just going to completely smother him
let's just talk about what's been
happening earlier because at uh prime
minister's questions uh this lunch time
boris johnson insisted that he plan to
hang on in there as he put it and keep
going he then faced the chairs of all
the common select committees at the
powerful liaison committee in a session
lasting about two hours he said he
couldn't see why he should resign when
he was questioned by labour's darren
jones
it's not brave for you to carry on doing
this i think in my view you're hurting
the country prime minister
just on a very human level surely you
must know that it's in the country's
interest for you to leave now isn't it i
i look i i think that the country's
going through tough times and i think
that we have the
uh the biggest uh you know you're making
a a point about about duty right yeah
and uh i i look at the uh the issues
that this country faces i look at the um
the pressures of people uh are under the
need for government to focus on that on
on on their priorities uh which is what
we are doing i look at uh the biggest
war in europe for 80 years and
i cannot for the life of me uh see or
how it is responsible just to to walk
away from that as i said earlier on in
uh in pmq's particularly not when you
have a mandate of the kind that
we won two three years ago
boris johnson there well let's speak now
to the labour mp chris bryant chair of
the committee's on standards and
privileges and who was at that liaison
committee hearing and uh thank you for
being with us what did you make first of
all of boris johnson's
performance in the liaison committee
well it was all the usual stuff wasn't
it it's kind of bluster and
um sort of billy bunter nonsense um he
never wants to accept responsibility for
anything um
he always wants to
sort of let people off let himself off
um
and and it's quite it was i mean what
was really bizarre about a meeting was
it felt surreal because we were talking
about questions he was saying things
like we're going to i'll get back to you
um next week on that and i was thinking
you're not going to be getting back to
anybody i don't think um not least
because some of us could look at our
phones and we could see what was going
on outside and we had a better idea of
what was happening to him than he did
there's one thing that really really
worried me though
and he
he uses this term his mandate
as if
it was a presidential election and it's
not we don't run a presidential election
in this country we have a parliamentary
system and that means he is accountable
to parliament if he loses the confidence
of parliament he's out as prime minister
but also if he loses the confidence of
his conservative mps which it's pretty
clear he already has then he's out as
leader of the conservative party and we
have to have a new prime minister but he
seems to be saying he was still gonna
cling on like like some barnacle or like
rasputin in the icy flows you have to
kind of stamp on his hands to make sure
that he's gone
yeah i mean he did seem to rule out a
snap election but what do you make of
what is happening after after we tried
five times with him
yeah yeah but what do you make of what
is happening here right now which is
this
group of cabinet ministers in there uh
telling him that it is time to go
well if that's what they're doing uh i
know why didn't they do that six months
ago why didn't they do that after um
boris johnson completely mishandled the
whole owen patterson scandal why didn't
they do that um over you know the lying
over partygate there are so many moments
when boris's boris johnson has proved
himself completely
personally unable to learn
from an event
um
and they
i would have thought that conservative
mps i mean they knew what they were
getting when they elected him
they knew it because this is him this is
how he operates the reason some of his
allies his closest allies in particular
took liberties
is because they know that he takes
liberties and he doesn't mind other
people taking liberties there's no sense
of um
you know that i think some people in the
country for a while thought oh it's
rather charming having somebody who
doesn't always play by the rules but
actually when you when you have somebody
as prime minister who tears up the
rulebook all the time and they scandal
after scandal after scandal after
scandal and there'll be more next week
and the week after if he remains in
office there just comes a point at which
people have to go all right
up with this we will not put
but doesn't it benefit you in a sense if
he stays in power and staggers
from one crisis to another and
you know it makes things easier for you
in a sense because the tory party will
be in utter disarray
i'm terribly sorry to sam pius but i'm
going to i mean in the end this is about
the country's future not about um any
political party future and you know you
could argue that it would be better for
us for the labor party for boris johnson
to stay in place and we fight him in the
next general election because i think
the voters would um you know deal the
final blow but to be honest look we've
got a
an international crisis in ukraine and
we've got a national crisis in terms of
the cost of living um which is meaning
that people are worrying about whether
to heat or eat and
and you cannot face either of those
major challenges
with the prime minister led by a prime
minister who has no moral authority left
because um you know there was even this
extraordinary moment earlier on this
week when
um one of the daily mail journalists
asked the downing street press lobby
are you going to tell us the truth today
government you govern my consent
if you don't have the consent of the
british people because you've lost the
trust of the british people in what
you're saying being the truth
then you're toast i mean you may not be
fully toasted toast but you're certainly
toast
yeah but my point is that all new
political leaders all new prime
ministers have a honeymoon period and
you know have a pretty good time in the
polls
do they i mean i think the difficulty
for the conservative party is that boris
johnson has corrupted the whole of the
conservative party you know all those
people have been on television and
defended him day in day out for for ages
they are the people who you know will
now be wanting to take over the
conservative party and we're just going
to say sorry mate
i remember what you did i remember you
defending all the in the indefensible
time and time again and you know i mean
there are people who are resigning as
pps's tonight
really bit late
bit late if you couldn't spot the
writing on the wall when it was seven
foot high and it was in um you know
flaming letters
you shouldn't be in politics
all right well listen on that very
subject i think we've got another
resignation uh beth rigby is with me uh
chris bryant by the way thank you very
much indeed uh beth what is the latest
resignation this is a more junior a
resignation this is a trade envoy david
digood now resigns
that's the total tally is now a
37 when i
started watching the liaison committee
at 3 p.m so that was what two and a half
hours ago it was 27 so that's 10 more
resignations
in the past two and a half hours and
it's getting busy in there now we've got
sir graham brady has gone round uh via
the cabinet office uh presumably for an
audience with the prime minister's chief
whip chris heaton harris is in there who
else is in there his arch supporter
nadine doris has gone in no doubt to try
and shore him up we've got pretty
patella in there we've got anne-marie
trevelyan in there and then we've got
who we know
are because we've been told by their
allies and other sources that they are
in this delegation asking him to leave
let's see if i can remember
grant shap simon hart brandon lewis
quasi kwa tang wants him to go
kit mart house michelle donnellan who is
the new um education secretary
isn't it
it's just easier to say it was dominic
dominic wright went to the isn't there
dominic
liz truss isn't there uh jacob rees-mogg
is not there um
mark spencer is not there so there are
uh some who are uh not uh partaking in
aleister jack actually the scotland's
secretary of state i haven't uh seen him
i'm not sure where he is so there are uh
some george eustis the the the uh
environment secretary uh he's gone to
ground so so it's not everyone but by
far it's not everyone not comfortable no
it's been a very uncomfortable day for
the prime minister but is it tenable
that given what you've just said given
the names of the people who are in there
is it tenable that he could say nope
i'm not going and if you want to resign
resign he
look convention would suggest that if
that number of cabinet ministers are
saying to the prime minister you no
longer command our confidence and we
think it's time for you to go
historically the precedent would be that
the prime minister would recognize his
time was up or her time and they would
stand down but this is boris johnson and
he does things differently i mean part
of his appeal
during the brexit referendum and into
that general election was the fact that
he did politics differently that he
managed to reach parts of the electorate
that other conservatives couldn't reach
i mean you remember they called him the
heineken uh politician because he had
this appeal that other people couldn't
seem to harness right so so he was
deeply popular he does things
differently so he might well say
i am not stepping down you're going to
have to vote me out in which case then
we move to another process which is the
22 committee then we'll call i think a
confidence vote in him
but either which way mark it's hard to
see how he's going to be in them for
much more tally i'm just looking at on
the screen at 38 someone else has gone
james sunderland i'm told a pps uh
from defra
so the tally goes on but no other
senior cabinet ministers
resigning no because there have been two
resignations and what the cabinet
ministers are doing instead is they're
saying we'd like you to resign and if
you don't resign then we will resign
from your cabinet so we will just make
it impossible uh for you to govern uh
the country i mean that's a point do we
reach a point do we reach a point soon
38 government resignations do we reach a
point soon when
you know
it's going to be impossible for him to
govern that's exactly but mark that's
that's exactly the conversation i
imagine the chief will be having with
him which will be
38 people have resigned i don't know if
i can fill the post i mean one
former
minister was saying to me this morning
that colleagues were saying don't to the
whips don't bother phoning me i don't
want to serve in the government right so
so that is an issue not just the level
of resignations but have you got the
talent or the
willing the willingness within the
parliamentary party uh to join
the government so that is a huge problem
now
people politicians are canny in that
they will sense that this is a sinking
ship
they will think is it in my interest to
try and prop up
this failing uh government and failing
prime minister any longer and they'll
probably think no i don't want to do any
of that also you have to think about how
it looks for their constituents i mean
lots of lots of constituents have been
you know very unhappy with what's gonna
listen to uh
making his way across westminster saying
that the prime minister
uh has his support so uh
so he look he still does have
some supporters those who are mentioning
dominic raab liz trust hasn't really
said anything not here as far as we know
so
i mean is it possible he goes on it it
just seems that it's just seeping away
certainly at the junior ranks it's
seeping away isn't it you can have the
support of some cabinet visitors but if
a number of your cab cabinet does not
support you you have a real problem
there's no other way for me
to put it yes jacob me smog might be in
support yes nadine doris might still
support him yes a number of cabinet
ministers might want to keep their
council and not form part of this
delegation but you've had two his
chancellor has resigned
he's the most second most important
person in government in the middle of a
cost of living crisis he's lost his
chancellor he's lost his health
secretary
at the moment when kovid is beginning uh
to cases have grown again and there's a
huge backlog at the nhs to the two
issues most on voters minds the cost of
living and healthcare and he's lost the
cabinet ministers i mean you can't run
the government if you can't manage your
cabinet and you can't manage your
departments
and on the subject of the health
secretary or the former health secretary
sajin javid made a statement in the
comments today a personal statement in
the commons explaining
the reasons for his resignation
treading the tightrope between loyalty
and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white old friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue grey report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
there we are that was the former health
secretary uh speaking earlier in the
comments beth rugby with me on her phone
well she has been raised
most of the day but we can understand
that it was a very powerful
statement by sajid javid personal
statement by sajid javid and are we
being mischievous to say that it was
also sounded a little bit like a job
application
i mean it was clearly a job application
that the guy has ambitious the
chancellor
he ran for leadership in in 2019
so it would be odd to think that he
might not try and take a to take a tilt
at the top job again whether he has the
support in the party we'd have to wait
and see but he's definitely decided um
to break ranks he he in his view saw the
writing on the wall both uh teams the
sonic team and
the javid team last night when we were
asking them about these decisions was it
a calculation was it packed between
these two men might they run on a double
ticket all of these questions we
obviously asked i mean the view from
javid's camp very much was this was all
about integrity and him being a
politician of integrity and i think what
you saw with both sunak and javid's
resignations
were that they were all predicated on we
are politicians of integrity and you saw
um sadhu javid really drill into that in
the commons
today when he talked about enough being
enough that he couldn't in good
conscience keep defending this he said
he said actually in the comments he said
it's not fair on cabinet ministers
having to go out to defend lines that
keep changing it's not fair on mps
having to try and defend
the government's conduct
against on the doorstep with with angry
voters and it's not fair to the
conservative
party voters and supporters
that they've been let down by the
government that was sajid javid's pitch
but within all of that was a lot about
who i am as a politician
which i think was the firing gun wasn't
it on um on the leadership but listen to
let's just stick with boris johnson for
a moment because he's in big trouble
tonight but
yeah i mean most of it is self-inflicted
isn't it what has happened it's not
policy there's not you know great
disputes within the tory part i mean
there probably are but not not huge
disputes on policy it is about his
personal integrity and his honesty and
so forth but he's brought it all on
himself my right to say that i've sort
of been reflecting on that
a bit mark because i remember at the
beginning of of
2020 uh before the covered pandemic
struck in february into march and i
remember thinking we're going to be
doing politics very differently from the
past decade when i'd been covering
westminster because he had got the sort
of majority we hadn't seen since the
days of tony blair and labour went on to
you know be in government for three
times he had a ginormous majority of 80
mps it was the most successful uh run at
the election
since the for a conservative leader
since the days of margaret thatcher
before that we'd had a coalition
government with david cameron and nick
clegg of the lib dems that was that was
quite contested and and um and
politically difficult then we had a
small majority for cameron then we had
theresa may with a minority government
propped up by the dup and and the
politics have been scrappy and it was
hard to get policy through and it had
all been about the political battles and
factions and rivalry and then boris
johnson won this huge majority and i
thought well that's it then it's going
to be you know he's going to do whatever
he wants and what we'll have to really
drill in
his own policy and is he going to
deliver the promises he made and then we
fast forward to two and a half years and
he is about to be ousted from number 10
despite that huge success and then you
think as you said how did that come to
pass and it wasn't two and a half years
after and it wasn't about
policy issues it was about politics it
was about character and it was about his
personal conduct
and that is perhaps for him the most
difficult thing i would imagine that you
have to accept which is that really
these are
what we have seen is a series of
unforced errors from the prime minister
that has led him to this place and i
remember so about the people he
surrounded himself with one thinks back
to the whole dominic cummings saga and
you know he's had well i mean how many
teams has he had i don't know but
some mps would argue
uh that part of his problem in terms of
politics and policy delivery
was the way in which he stacked the
cabinet with arch loyalists that he
cauterized really parts of the party so
he didn't make it an inclusive cabinet
so sort of those that were remainers or
those that had challenged him such as a
jeremy hunt a very accomplished minister
he was put out to pasture as was people
like greg clark the former business
minister so remainers really or one
nation conservatives that maybe weren't
arch brexiteers so he excluded a big
chunk of the party so you make natural
enemies anyway
and then some people would argue that
what he did as one former cabinet
minister put it to me was he surrounded
himself with short poppies
i he wanted to be the king he wanted to
be
not fast among equals but just above
everyone else around him and that
loyalty mattered more to him
than political execution and ability
that's what some of his detractors would
say and there was a view i think with
some of those in the conservative party
that he had built around him
a weak cabinet in order to make sure he
didn't have confrontations like he's now
getting and to ensure his uh support but
that actually became in the end achilles
heel because he couldn't get
policy done
and he didn't have enough ability around
the table that's what some uh in his
party have have have put to me
it is really an extraordinary
political drama uh beth stay with us we
await the
verdict on what's happened in there how
has boris johnson reacted to these
ministers who are in there you're
watching the newshour on sky news the
newshour at six coming up
cabinet ministers are gathering here at
number 10 to tell boris johnson it is
time to go
it's over
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to downing street cabinet
ministers have gathered here at number
10 to tell the prime minister to resign
it comes as 38 mps have now handed in
their resignation that's in the last 24
hours the home office minister kit
malthouse has just left the cabinet
office
let's just have a listen uh to what he's
got to say
what's happening in
there for a long time
it's over isn't it
is
[Music]
kit malt house there policing minister
difficult day he said which is uh
putting it mildly um how significant
could he be in all this well not
commenting there but not saying as
nadine doris did that she was still that
he was still supporting the prime
minister saying only to that uh gaggle
of reporters chasing him down whitehall
that it had been a difficult day and he
wasn't commenting
but we do know from other sources that
kit malthouse was one of those
senior figures in the party
along with those cabinet ministers that
had gone in
and told boris johnson or perhaps
related to the whip the chief whip chris
heaton harris to tell boris johnson we
don't know if he saw him face to face uh
that he thought it was time for him to
resign and as we were saying earlier
mark that the reason why kit malt house
is significant is kit malthouse has been
with the prime minister
for a number of years in his political
career they they go back all the way to
city hall
when boris johnson was london mayor and
boris johnson has kept kit mart house in
positions
in his government you know you would say
if you say who were boris johnson's
allies uh kit malt house would certainly
be viewed as one of them so for kit mart
house uh to go in and and say to the
prime minister the time you know your
time is up uh that that's that's
difficult for the pm i i would imagine
because he is a really loyal ally
i have to say what i'm what i'm
interested in as well is pretty patel
is in there now she too is a very very
close ally to the prime minister she
supported him when he was london she
campaigned from a lot they go back a
long way she was instrumental
in getting him into power in 2019 i
can't get a handle on whether she's in
there to support him
or as part of the delegation uh
those in her team and around her simply
won't say we've got to wait for her to
come out but pretty patel is in there
right i've got a couple of guests uh
coming up now but just pull all this
together for us uh briefly where are we
then there's cabinet ministers in there
we've had the meeting of
tory mps which is over
so
look where are we do you think tonight
we're now in a position of waiting to
see what boris johnson does next whether
he heeds
the
request from his cabinet to do what they
would say is the honorable thing and the
only tenable thing actually now they
would view it which would be um to for
him to to resign
and if that doesn't work and and he
chooses not to which is his prerogative
uh then what we do is we roll over into
this position now where the party uh
will
hold a confidence vote we'll change the
rules to hold a confidence vote to force
him out but either which way mark it's
hard to see how he can continue
uh past the coming few days okay beth
for a moment uh thanks very much stay
with me not a chance i can do this
without you uh let's speak uh to
sebastian payne who is the white wall
editor at the financial times lauren
mckevitt a former conservative special
adviser thank you
both for joining me uh lauren first of
all
do you think the game is effectively up
absolutely i think that if you've lost
this many ministers within 24 hours if
you've got the 1922 committee a hundred
years old this year
saying that it wants to change the rules
to oust you those rules are in place for
really good reasons and it's
traditionally been quite hard to
arbitrarily get rid of conservative
leaders and and in certain parts of our
history that's been quite a good thing
for the 1922 committee to be considering
upending that rule is monumental in
terms of the conservative party's
organization
and then if it doesn't work
the other options are even more
monumental he has he he is he's
seriously sitting in number 10
contemplating staring down the queen and
asking her to dissolve parliament to
call an election asking her to back him
and not call anybody else up to form a
government instead of him if he loses
the confidence of the mps but can't be
ousted by a vote we're in truly
extraordinary uh circumstances here for
the conservative party as an
organization um but yes i think he
absolutely has to go and he has to go
very soon if the party itself is going
to be salvageable
yeah extraordinary circumstances for the
country as well uh sebastian payne
what's your sense of
where we are tonight
well i don't think it could really be
more over than it is over right now the
simple fact is is that this cabinet
delegation in downing street right now
telling the prime minister that it's up
it's over and urging him to quit with
dignity and the real question is will he
do that throughout the past 24 hours of
remarkable events here in westminster uh
it's been said the prime minister will
not willingly or easily go he will cling
on to the last bitter moment and we've
now reached that point there was a
meeting of the 1922 committee executive
that lauren was just talking about and
they've decided not to change the past
leadership rules but what there will be
will be a series of contest positions on
that executive committee on monday and i
think if boris johnson is not gone by
monday the people in that conduct would
win um the slate that wants to change
the rules would win that and then they
would change that have a contest give
out the prime minister but i'd be quite
surprised if we get to that the fact is
i think the majority of the cabinet have
lost confidence in boris johnson you've
obviously seen rishi sunak and sanji
javed resign and i think what those
ministers will be telling boris johnson
right now is if you don't quit if you
stick around we'll quit and there's no
one left to replace them because we've
seen an extraordinary number of
resignations today i think 36 at the
last count from the government there
simply aren't any more conservative mps
let alone credible mps who could take
the place of the cabinet so it is over
it's just a question now of exactly how
it ends
yeah it's uh 38 i think now sebastian
and um um sebastian just you say it
could go
to the mps i mean do you honestly think
that
if these cabinet ministers in downing
street behind me here tell him to go
he could say no i'm fighting on and and
let it go to the
process of the mps
well if boris johnson does really fight
on as his allies have been urging and
saying that he will do then i think that
certainly could happen he could say i'm
not going anywhere my mandate comes from
the british people who voted for the
last election not conservative mps not
the party and that if you want to get
rid of me then you'd have to call a
general election now i don't buy
anything into that even though the prime
minister did hint at that
liaison committee appearance earlier so
yes he might try and dig in but i think
if he does that the fundamental point is
that the cabinet will just resign and
there'll be no one left to run the
country i think at that point you get to
a very murky constitutional area because
of course while we're watching this in
westminster just up just up the mile at
buckingham palace they will be watching
events very carefully too and there will
be a moment of course when it's clear
boyce johnson does not have the
confidence the house of commons it
doesn't it doesn't have the confidence
the conservative party and doesn't have
the confidence to cabinet then they
might look at ways of signaling that he
needs to go as well and of course no one
wants to get into that tricky
constitutional water but if he does
stick around when the cabinets say his
position is untenable then we'll be in
unprecedented times and i don't think
anyone would want to predict what
exactly will happen
yeah that's an interesting point to make
lauren you've got experience of these
things well you probably haven't got an
experience of anything quite like this
but you've been in sight
you know downing street with david
cameron and so forth just give us a
sense if you can of what will be going
on within the johnson
team what will they be doing what will
they be thinking about what will what
will be happening
mark i don't think anybody who's gone
before this team
could in any way indicate what's going
on in there you have two rival teams of
cabinet members like west side story one
half of whom are trying to pass the
prime minister a whiskey and a revolver
the other half of whom is still
cheerleading on his behalf i don't see
how any a political or apolitical
can handle this situation with you know
delicacy or finesse we are truly beyond
the looking glass of anything that the
conservative party has experienced in
the past
doing the decent thing appears to be
completely beyond the realms of
possibility for this prime minister and
i don't understand how it is that in any
recess of anyone's mind they could be
considering that a general election when
we do not have a party chairman
when it is highly unlikely we'll be uh
will be able to fundraise significantly
enough for a war chest for a snap
election and by the way when it's highly
unlikely that there'll be any
conservative party
prospective candidates willing to stand
for the party in election that's where
we might have some really difficult
troubles is trying to get people on the
approved parliamentary candidates list
to stick their head above this
particular parapet and stick their flags
to this mast this is a completely
unprecedented situation
even when gordon brown was struggling to
come to terms with leaving downing
street it wasn't this undignified and i
think that any aid within number 10
right now who isn't lining up behind the
cabinet ministers handing out the
whiskey and the revolver is making a
huge mistake on behalf of our party
because i think the prime minister is
wrong we don't elect a president in this
country we elect an individual
representative that representative goes
to westminster the majority party in
westminster forms a government with a
prime minister by majority approval of
the governing party
we do not elect a president and he must
stop behaving like one because he's
doing it badly
and just another quick thought from
sebastian and does there come a time
sebastian when boris johnson is unable
to govern have we reached the time when
he's unable to govern
well obviously we've had as you said
about those 38 minister of resignations
and i don't think there's much thought
in downing should go into how they're
going to replace all those people who
have quit government because i think
very much at that point the exact moment
he's unable to govern is if the cabinet
walks away and you see a mass
resignation from that delegation that
told him it's over and he simply can't
feminist shakespeare and some government
departments the department of education
for example there's actually one
minister left the secretary of state in
the department for leveling up there's
just one minister left and that's
michael gov everyone else has quit the
department today so you know the the the
ship is clearly sinking and everybody is
fleeing it very very quickly i think you
know as i said it really is just up to
the prime minister now about how sort of
dignified this exit can be because i
don't see the mps we're going to take
over this role don't imagine anyone who
would want to at this exact juncture and
yes he might try some wild ruses to keep
his government going but i think through
our voiceover's time as prime minister
we've always said he defies the laws of
political gravity that he does things no
other prime minister can do that he's
the teflon leader the fact is that the
laws of political gravity do kick in
we're seeing that right now in
westminster and there's absolutely no
escaping from that fact
sebastian payne and uh lauren mckevitt
thank you both very much indeed and uh
beth rigby is still with me and beth i
mean this number
in the top right hand corner of that
script 38 mps have now
resigned
yeah and sky news has done
some number crunching and actually
this is a record of ministers that have
resigned in one day
never has it been higher than this 14
ministerial resignations
in one day
the last time
a number anywhere near that was
approached was back in 1932
when 11
ministers resigned and the reason i'm
giving you that stat is to try and
really impress upon everyone just how
extraordinary this is this was
started by two cabinet resignations and
then it snowballed uh into this
series of resignations and also letters
from backbench mps go in public to say
we cannot support you anymore prime
minister and now we have 38
mps have resigned from government and
the sev was saying that
part of the issue for boris johnson and
actually there's i'm just looking
because i saw some outriders going
across we're waiting for boris johnson
to come back to number 10 from
parliament but as said payne was saying
there part of the problem he's got now
is how on earth does he feel the
government posts that have been left
absent particularly if he doesn't heed
these appeals from cabinet
and decide to try and stay on then what
you're facing is potential uh mass
cabinet resignations and the gates are
open in derby and another cars coming in
and i don't know if that is uh the pm or
not but um
we'll keep an eye we'll keep her now
down the street because we'll be derby
huh should you just call me dermot i
call you david i'm sorry i can see that
that's because i can see derma it's okay
we've got bigger things too
we can see bigger things to worry about
but anyway let's let's see who it is um
but we know that there's a number of
cabinet ministers in there
um
and the question is uh what does boris
johnson do next and that is a big
unknown i have to say and that's the
fallback process of the the mps now as
well that's exactly right the fallback
process of the mps
which is if the prime minister doesn't
go of his own accord they will force him
out
so it's just uh it's funny isn't it
boris johnson was sometimes described
not particularly nice analogy as a
greased piglet i think
that that was the description that maybe
some of his old
colleagues put upon him because he
seemed to escape from every single
scrape and and just managed to survive
and you know skip free and and keep
going but now finally it seems that
tonight
the whole scandal that emerged around
chris pincher has been the story of you
like that broke the camel's back a
senior a former cabinet minister said to
me the other day when we were talking
about when might boris johnson go could
he survive
they said to me that they thought it
would be a death by a thousand cuts that
there would be
a series of scandals or missteps or
disappointments that eventually would
tip enough of the party over the edge uh
to make his position untenable and and
you know you never know when that moment
would come was it going to be the
by-elections 10 days ago
and now here we are the mo the moment is
here
but it seems extraordinary that you know
when an issue
like sexual misconduct in the workplace
like predatory behavior in the workplace
is such a a you know touchstone issue
and quite rightly that it is
he just seemed to have a blind spot on
that with
uh chris pincher it was allegations but
there was do you think it's fair to say
he's admitted there was a blind spot
because he said i should have
you know acted differently i think
i don't think it was necessarily about
chris pincher per se it was about what
it represented exactly right it was
about the fact that what it represented
was a few things in the short term
number 10 was saying one thing and
changing the story and not telling the
truth which mps was sick and tired of
because that was the whole saga in
partygate the prime minister saying he
knew nothing and then slowly it built
and built a bill until they eventually
ended up with 126 fixed penalty notices
over eight different events
so that that that was you know that was
the kind of line uh in the sand there
and then this happened and then again
the prime minister wasn't aware of
allegations then he wasn't aware of
specific allegations only for it to
emerge that he was aware of a formal
complaint made in 2019 against chris
pincher when he was foreign secretary
and for many mps what that smacked off
was this guy
does not have a moral compass in terms
of how he runs the cat who he thinks is
okay to appoint and also he's not being
truthful
in terms of what he's telling us now
that's the view of some mps and that's
what took them over the edge but i think
as i said in terms of what it
represented it was represented the
inability really of the number 10
operation to get a grasp on events to
run the government properly to get back
onto policy rather than being constantly
embroiled in political scandal and it
wasn't just chris pincher it was the
by-election losses that rattled the
party it was lord guyt his ethics
advisor in the end resigning because of
the prime minister's conduct it was you
know it was partygate and all of the
issues around that so you know there
were a number you know it started really
i think back with owen patterson uh when
when uh sorry i thought when when the
prime minister sought to defend him and
ask the party to defend him when they
felt it was indefensible and you have
enough a number of small grievances if
you like and it builds up and then of
course with the chris pitcher you're
quite right why was someone who had had
multiple allegations made against them
and a formal complaint made
against them why was he put in a
position of power where he was dealing
with the welfare of mps and for some it
was just
unconscionable just hearing in my ear
that boris johnson is due to speak to
the queen this evening uh on the phone
it's a routine
weekly uh i think she might be at
windsor castle yeah she
and so there's there is a phone call
taking place it's interesting to
speculate on how she would view
what's going on you love to be a corgi
on the floor
in that phone call wouldn't you want to
be
but it's a point sebastian payne made
the point and it is quite an interesting
one
um that uh and the queen has a very
clear
interest well the queen the queen of the
palace will in no way want to be
involved in any matters of government in
this way
but that might be a consideration for
the prime minister as well that he
wouldn't want to put the queen
in that sort of position because as
payne was saying
constitutional difficulties uh could
arise if uh he seeks to torpedo the
government
or you know call a general election
right beth we've got um what a minute
and a half or so uh until the end of uh
this particular program uh der
mcmernhand here to carry on uh but um
just to sum up for us
where are we
what is going on in there and what was
happening a little earlier with the mps
just bring us up to date
where we are now tonight mark is that we
are in the final moments really of boris
johnson's premiership that one way or
another
he can't really carry on he's lost
the support of a number of his cabinet
it looks like even potentially the
majority of his cabinet he's had
38 ministerial resignations the 1922
back bench committee on mobilizing to
change the rules to force him out unless
he resigns and it's interesting isn't it
that prime ministers have so much power
but once that authority begins to ever
weigh it can suddenly go very quickly
and overnight he has gone from being in
office there to being a man that is
about to be forced out of number 10
either by his own
uh his own decision or by his party so
what do you think the uh 30 seconds i
mean what do you think the timeline
could possibly be 30 seconds to read
because it depends on how boris johnson
reacts to this it depends on whether he
uh heeds the appeals from his cabinet
and it is divided i should say i mean
nadine doris is in there and she might
be leading
a little delegation of loyalists trying
uh to keep him in place it's not as
simple as everyone wanting him gone but
but the timeline of it depends on does
he heed
those warnings and decide the game is up
i'm standing down or does he carry on
and then there is a confidence vote in
him as early as next week okay that was
the newshour at six thanks for watching
der mcmurnan
is coming up
[Music]
[Music]
m
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm dermott manner
and this is sky news tonight live from
downing street where boris johnson's
premiership hangs in the balance
tonight he faces a delegation of cabinet
colleagues calling for him to step down
as leader and of course his prime
minister
among them his new chancellor nadine
zahawi after less than 24 hours in that
role
but mr johnson is adamant he'll stay the
course despite a bruising day of
questioning from mps in committee and in
the house of commons
between loyalty and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i'm not going to give her a running
commentary on political events and we're
going to get on with the government of
the country
well the prime minister's future now
rests with the influential committee of
conservative back benches the 1922
committee it's been meeting throughout
the day
[Music]
a very good evening live from downing
street where for a second night the
prime minister is fighting for his very
political survival having faced 38
government resignations today alone he
tonight faced a delegation of cabinet
ministers who are calling for him to
resign now we await
what mr johnson has to say after that
meeting it is still continuing here at
number 10 downing street at prime
minister's questions earlier today he
insisted he plans to hang on in there
and keep going he then faced a two-hour
session with all the chairs of the house
of commons committees the all-powerful
liaison committee there mr johnson said
he couldn't see why he should resign
when questioned by labour's darren jones
it's not brave for you to carry on doing
this i think in my view you're hurting
the country prime minister
just on a very human level surely you
must know that
it's in the country's interest for you
to leave now isn't it i i look i i think
that the country is going through tough
times and i think that we have the
uh the biggest
you know you're making a a point about
about duty right yeah and
uh i i look at the uh the issues that
this country faces i look at the um
the pressures of people uh are under the
need for government to focus on that on
on their priorities uh which is what we
are doing i look at uh the biggest war
in europe for 80 years
and
i cannot for the life of me
see or how it is responsible just to
walk away from that as i said earlier on
in uh in pmq's particularly not when you
have a mandate of the kind that
we won
two three years ago
well with no prospective resignation
from the prime minister his future now
lies with the 1922 committee the
influential group of back bench
conservative mps now they've been
meeting throughout the day in the
evening so let's take a look at them and
their role so they meet every week
formally when the house of commons is
sitting to set the rules for the
conservative party it marshals votes of
confidence of course in the leader and
after facing one of those votes you'll
remember just last month boris johnson
should be safe from another for a year
those are the existing rules but now the
group is considering membership and rule
changes that could allow another vote to
take place much sooner nominations for
new executive members are open right now
and we'll close we're here on monday
afternoon with results later that
evening well after those election
results the committee can then discuss
any potential rule changes to allow
another vote of confidence sooner that
means boris johnson could face another
confidence vote perhaps within weeks or
even days after that however any vote
would need to take place before
parliament goes on its summer recess
that's taking place in just over two
weeks time or if it doesn't happen it
would be delayed until after the fourth
of september when they come back well
our political editor beth rigby is here
with me now so beth how this all pans
out all depends on what is going on
behind us right here right now
there are a number of cabinet ministers
in there right now uh the chief whip
chris heaton harris is in there we also
know that sir graham brady
who is the chair of the 1922
back bench committee he basically is the
envoy of all the back benches has also
gone in via the cabinet office who
didn't walk up the street
and we know that there are
at least half a dozen
half a dozen cabinet ministers who are
in there as a delegation to tell boris
johnson that they think now is the time
for him to resign and if he doesn't then
they will leave his government that he
has lost their confidence but there's
also other cabinet ministers in there
nadine dorrie's for sure who is in there
to back boris johnson up so there's
cabinet ministers in there
and some division and dermot i honestly
tonight at the moment
what will boris johnson do you know he
has said repeatedly
all the time that i've interviewed him
in recent weeks about his future and his
fate he's very clearly repeated in the
comments today i have been given a
colossal mandate he would say i have
been given the support of 14 million
voters in 2019 i was the most successful
prime minister at a ballot box for the
conservatives since the days of margaret
thatcher and you guys are not going to
force me out my mandate is via the
public not by you
so you know in his heart his instinct
will be to fight to the very end so it
would have to have i mean just sort of
deject there but of course if he fights
the very end as it stands now what we
know you know we're only imagining what
might be taking place in there and as
you say we can't know but what we do
know is the number of ministerial
resignations that took place today you
cannot function as the prime minister
without a government no but he might i
don't know he might say i'm not going to
resign bring it on force this confidence
that you have to force me out now that
would go against all convention i mean
if the if you end up with you know a
sizeable chunk if not the majority of
your cabinet quietly tapping on your
shoulder saying you've lost the
confidence of the cabinet you've lost
the confidence of the parliamentary
party you've lost 38
mps from your government you actually
can't run your government you can't run
the country at that point most prime
ministers would say the game's up i've
got to go but you know i i can't predict
uh what boris johnson will do all i can
tell you is what i have seen in his mind
which was a fierce determination
come what made to carry on which is why
how this plays out tonight will be so
interested in what he decides to do in
the coming hours so if it does come down
to the 1922 committee as i described
there you know they're changing the
committee their elections to the
committee they could then change the
rules and perhaps hold a vote sometime
next week if they do change those rules
is there another way that that could be
speeded up if graham brady has gone in
there the chair of the committee and
said well look you know i've already got
these letters coming through prime
minister they're in the hundreds now or
whatever plus the number of resignations
you've had from your ministerial ranks
you presumably voted for your last time
the game's up yeah you're quite right
dumb i mean what graham buried he can do
is go in and say to the prime minister
look i've got a parliamentary majority
have sent me letters saying
that he wants the pm um
to resign that they want the prime
minister to resign and graham brady
could show the evidence and say i can
tell you
you will be forced out in a confidence
vote unless you resign
so i'm just i'm a bit jumpy because i'm
i'm kind of looking around just to see
what's moving around but um
yes he
he could uh graham brady could just say
to him these are the facts you cannot
stay on you will be voted out and then
the cabinets say you have to resign
and at that point boris johnson will
have to take his decision but in terms
of the process of the 22 there was talk
earlier today before this sort of
crescendo really built with the
resignations that they might try and
force a rule change uh for next week or
rule change now with a vote next week or
a vote even earlier than that and
actually tonight the committee didn't
decide to change the rules they've just
brought forward the elections of a new
executive they were going to do that
right before recess
and they're going to do that next monday
so if he doesn't go in the next few days
at that point they could
trigger a vote but i have to say
it's hard to see how it comes to that
if
there is a mass walk out of the cabinet
and it's clear that he will lose that
vote but we'll have to see i just want
to get your take on you know those that
we think are telling mr johnson that
time is up as prime minister nadine
zahari
still less than 24 hours
chancellor of the extractor that would
be quite extraordinary if he has now
decided after we heard him all over the
the breakfast programs this morning
telling us what a good job the prime
minister was doing if he's now telling
him to go he is in the delegation i've
been i've been told that my colleague
sam coats has been told that uh by
different sources we've both been told
that nadeem zahari is in the delegation
telling the prime minister that it's
time for us to resign and i did ask
someone i said well hang on a minute why
did he accept the job last night
if he didn't have confidence in the
prime minister
and this person said to me if the prime
minister taps you on the shoulder and
says please serve as my chancellor it's
very difficult to say no because the
country needs a chancellor
but more machiavellian view could be
that he'd already decided to go and
decide he he decided that the prime
minister needed to go and decide tried
to orchestrate
uh this to happen are you hearing
anything about um you know the phone
there's a reversal indeed
used to be well let's keep a close eye
on that and talk this way um the
the potential leadership challenges
putting teams in place covertly and
things like that let's just see who's
getting out of this
uh jacob rees-mogg i've just been told
in my ear that jacob rees-mogg is going
into whitehall
so he's going to maybe see what's going
on uh within
uh number 10. we know jacob rees-mogg is
a key ally that'd be extraordinary if
jacob reese mark
because i'm pretty confident of this
that jacob rees-mogg will be going in to
stand next to nadine doris and defending
the prime minister rather than calling
for anything else he's a die-hard
loyalists so it's interesting that these
two camps
are inside number 10. the unknown is i
don't know where pretty patel stands
because she's in there and i know that
she has been an uber loyalist to boris
johnson they go back a long way but i
can't get a handle on which way what
about liz trust
liz truss is out of the country uh so we
we don't know about livestream she has
left the country it might be the best
thing to do at the moment shades of john
major
dental appointment and brandon lewis
who's part of the delegation that uh
think that the position of the prime
minister is untenable he's actually in
belfast flying back you've then got
simon hart uh the welsh secretary you've
got kit mart house uh the policeman i'm
sorry i'm just a bit jumpy you keep an
eye on that that's waiting
there's a door so someone coming out
we've got uh someone i want to talk to
now about uh boris johnson pauline
latham uh was a
firm supporter of the prime minister
good to see you pauline latham but uh of
course broke um with mr johnson uh over
partygate wasn't it earlier this year um
tell us what you think the prime
minister should do if he is in there
being told by
cabinet members
colleagues to go
well i don't think anybody can have any
doubt about what he must do he has to
resign you can't have so many ministers
and cabinet members resigning and just
stay where you are you just can't do it
i mean it's in untenable and it's never
in my knowledge ever happened before and
it's a farce it's a complete fuss and it
does make you wonder what his mindset is
because he's like
a wounded animal desperately trying to
stop being killed and actually he needs
to move across and allow
room for somebody new who can run the
country
properly
with a moral campus to come forward so
that we can get back on track and take
the country forward because there's
enough issues to deal with and he's not
dealing with them
i i want to ask you about uh as you
described his moral compass uh going
wonky i suppose from your point of view
but what happens if he doesn't if he
decides you describe him as a wounded
animal he decides to fight on
well i don't i genuinely don't see how
he can if he's not got the confidence of
the parliamentary party which i don't
believe he has anymore he's certainly
not going to have enough people to
replace all these ministers and pbs's
who have resigned
rightly in my view
you can't replace them all so how is he
going to run a government without the
right people in place it just doesn't
work and
it makes him look stupid it makes a
conservative culture looks stupid if we
can't move on and get on with governing
the country when there's enough issues
that need sorting out we have to do it
we cannot
say oh prime minister you've got to stay
i don't know how anybody can do that now
it's just gone too far
and if it does come down to the 1922
committee having to organize another
vote of confidence change the rules and
allow that to happen are you certain
that the prime minister would lose it
this time of course he won what was it
by 211 to 184 just four or five weeks
ago
i'm absolutely certain he would lose it
i cannot see how he could survive that
but i don't want them to change the
rules i don't
believe that we should change the rules
just to suit local circumstances at the
time it should be a long term considered
thing to change rules maybe we need to
look at that later but i think that the
prime minister should do the right thing
he has shown that he hasn't got the
confidence of his ministers and pps's he
really hasn't got the confidence of
everybody and i have to say the
atmosphere in
parliament today has been glum everybody
is depressed we need to move on and he
needs to recognize that
i don't like to say this about my prime
minister but
i think the time has come where he
should see the writing on the wall and
he should move on
just uh pause there
transport secretary grant shaps exiting
the building
very quickly there nothing to say there
the car was waiting uh right outside the
door of number ten straight in a uh
tight lipped i think is the phrase brah
chap so pauline latham
let's then look at if he does go if you
get what you want he goes now or fairly
soon
you say you want to move on but then of
course the party has to go through
an election process in choosing the next
leader and prime minister and given the
number of runners and riders potentially
that could be a pretty bruising process
you don't get that stability you crave
for quite a while
well we do have a deputy prime minister
who is perfectly capable of running the
country until that time until we have
chosen the next leader so there's
absolutely no reason why
we couldn't move on and we couldn't have
a leadership campaign
um which as you say is fairly protracted
because it has to be to make sure
we get the right person
but
we have got a very competent deputy who
could do we've got a chancellor
and we've got a health secretary and i'm
sure that if they knew
that there was going to be a new prime
minister other people would step up and
take the jobs that are vacant
that uh have you got anyone that you
personally would like to see taking over
you don't have to tell me their name but
do you have someone in mind
no i don't and that i think has been one
of the difficulties um why it hasn't
happened before in my view
i want to see who the runners and riders
are and then i will listen to what i've
got to say and see who best aligns with
what i want the government to do
and can i just ask you um you know back
to the here and now and uh the prime
minister and it's not just you saying it
lacking a moral compass or that it's uh
it's broken so 38 uh ministers pps's and
of course cabinet ministers in total
resigning since yesterday alone and
you're clearly not alone in that view
what was it for you that you
made you come to that decision
it's been an accumulation of things i
mean on a personal level boris has been
very helpful to me he's backed my power
my private member's bill the marriage
bill to raise the age of marriage to 18
he if he hadn't backed it it wouldn't
have gone through because they don't go
through without the prime minister's
backing so i'm sorry about this but i
just can't support him and i i really
feel that it's just been an accumulation
it started really with carter gate it
started with what looks
as if things have not been entirely
truthful and then it's finally i suppose
there's a chris pincher affair
and it's no good the promise to keep
coming saying oh i'm sorry i got that
wrong he seems to got quite a lot of
things wrong and if he's that bad at his
judgment he's not in the right job
well i think it's fair to uh describe
you as uh heavy-hearted uh pauline
nathan thank you very much for joining
us there from the central lobby there in
the houses of parliaments well uh we
mentioned there the 38 mps who resigned
from the government since just yesterday
including two cabinet ministers well
resignations continued this evening so
uh let me take you through the state of
play uh there are some of the pictures
since the resignation of the chancellor
and the health secretary last night
there's been a deluge of conservative
mps handing in their letters of
resignation the total as i say is 38
another conservative mp threatening to
resign if boris johnson doesn't step
down
well chief among them the former health
secretary sajid javid of course you
remember his dramatic resignation just
over 24 hours ago he made a statement in
the house of commons today explaining
his reasons for resigning
the tightrope between loyalty and
integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white olive friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue gray report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
well let's just fill you in on the
information uh we're hearing about
what's going on behind us in number 10
downey street you know the prime
minister is in there beth rigby with
cabinet colleagues telling him to go
some perhaps supportive of him we were
wondering what the position of pretty
patel would be the home secretary
from the times uh has just uh tweeted
out an exclusive which he must have
presumably picked up from some of her
team members saying that pretty patella
sided with a group of cabinet ministers
calling for the pm to go
um one of mr john that i mean principal
tellers are saying is one of uh boris
johnson's most loyal supporters so at
the times they're reporting that pretty
patel has not sided with nadine doris
and jacob rees-mogg who are also in
there but actually sided with the
delegation
saying that boris johnson needs to go on
the basis that
he cannot continue to govern with the
support of his party and i imagine if
pretty patel has done that she has done
it with a heavy heart because she has
been hugely supportive of the problem
she has been of her as he has been of
her and i have to wonder
whether when someone like pretty patel
puts it to him that it gives him pause
for thought because if your most loyal
lieutenants such as kitten mortal house
or pretty patel are telling you your
time is up and it's over
will he take that on board and heed that
advice big unanswered question beth
we're going to be addressing it i
suspect most of the evening i want to
talk now to lord howell let's get
an interesting perspective i think
because he's a former government
minister who served several prime
ministers
including of course margaret thatcher
lady thatcher good to talk to you lord
howell um thank you and i want to ask
you then about um you know the the end
days of uh margaret thatcher and her
premiership are there
different every time round i know but
are there some parallels between now
and 32 years ago or nearly 32 years ago
when senior cabinet members went in and
told the pm it's time to go
well there could be parallels because
remember what happened after that
was that the conservative party came to
a regret or a large part of it did that
that had ever occurred and the
calculation that um that someone else
would win the election although it
turned out to be right with sir john
major it was only just right and ever
since then there have been sore feelings
in the conservative party about the way
in which uh mrs sasha was told to go and
the feeling was then and i can't help
sharing it slightly now that in a sort
of frenzy mode when you've got the whole
media against you whenever the bbc
against you when you've got
denunciations on all sides and you long
to try and distinguish between the
purely partisan stuff which of course is
justified the opposition always pile in
and so on and the more reflective and
genuine and cool assessments you long to
hold off the final decision until
templars cool down a little bit and i
think probably that will happen because
this is procedure it's going to unfold
over the next fortnight also so perhaps
there will be
reflective thoughts if not second
thoughts but it's uh
a frenzy is not something that um
i suppose older generation of
politicians really welcome because it's
in fringes that sometimes the most
terrible mistakes are made
so would your advice lord howl to
current cabinet members be i suppose
it's the old axiom um act in haste
repent at leisure i think that could be
who knows um the
the whole mode is very much against uh
his survival
and on the other hand we are in the
moment this nation faces some terrifying
threats for the first time we're
rediscussing nuclear war in relation to
russia and ukraine the world is gripped
by the most hideous food shortages and
in imported inflation which is crippling
uh half the households of this country
we are in a very very serious and
desperate position uh and the protests
are mounting
um the uh many other the pandemic is
over but it has been some of the worst
challenges ever faced by governments i
mean this man this prime minister
whether you like him or not has had to
govern through three of the biggest
challenges or more as ireland as well of
course and the brexit thing through
bigger challenges ever faced by ever gov
any government anywhere we're in our a
world of seven billion people so even
compared with past pandemics and past
crisis this is enormous so let there be
some careful thinking
as to who the replacement is i'm not
sure anyone's got any idea they're
talking about runners and horses and so
on and so it's a the derby day when it
isn't at all uh and let them be careful
about who is going to
bring the conservative party which has
many factions and two very powerful
wings one particularly the one that went
for brexit and really boris johnson
wrote to power on let them consider very
carefully before they rush before they
rush because more haste as you say is
always less speed and we have to be very
careful what's going on what's going to
happen
lord hell would be interesting to get
your assessment though which seems to be
behind so much of the anger in his anger
within the party about mr johnson and
it's his personal qualities you know as
they describe it i don't know if you
would i want your take on it they
describe it you know his lack of a moral
compass was just hearing that from one
of his mps his lack of integrity
well you hear these things on all sides
of course very largely as i say from
opponents who don't like him personally
although it's not necessarily always
personal dislike is not necessarily
always the best guide to counseling or
thinking about the nation's welfare and
political stability but that's coming
from personal dislike it's coming from
political opponents of course in a flood
in the cascade as i just said and
amidst it all there are call reflections
which may be on the side of what you
just said that he's too casual with the
truth in certain things and doesn't
appear to detail and that leads him to
sort of
say what pleases people at the moment
even though it's not turned out to be
accurate all that may go on what i'm
saying is we're in an immensely
dangerous situation i think we need an
entirely new economic approach to this
hyperinflation hitting us and that's why
i rather not welcome the new chancellor
mr zaharia sounds a very sensible man
and frankly the policies so far are
simply getting it wrong they don't
understand how this inflation should be
addressed and i could give you a longer
interview five or six or seven months
which i know would bring down the
inflation rate immediately and therefore
bring down public expenditure and begin
to unravel the whole
head of steam into which is that would
be very interesting
yeah i mean clearly at a later date but
could i just ask you finally um you know
what would your advice to boris johnson
be right now who presumably is being
told you know the game is up it is time
to go
we don't know what his mindset is
whether he will will fight it all the
way and have to be dragged out there
kicking and screaming would you say look
it is whether you like it or not all
prime ministers their period in office
comes to an end either at elections or
through this process just go and go with
dignity
well i think that is you know that's for
him to decide i think he
if he really reckons that uh
the game is up then a sensible thing is
to go with dignity after all this takes
it could take with so many candidates in
the field it could take uh
several months to get up to the party
conference in october to get this
straight so
he will
there will have to be either a standing
uh the deputy prime minister or he will
have to stay on a few weeks
and
give the guidance country needs every
minute of the day as we face these
existential crises which are closing on
us around the world i think it's a very
very dangerous time into which to
where we should not rush we should move
very carefully indeed that's all i ask
well lord howl has been so interesting
talk to you thank you very much indeed
it would be great to interview at a
later date about those ideas you have
for
bringing down inflation but for the time
being thank you very much indeed now i
just want to check in with beth ruby our
political editor here with me in downing
street first of all because we were
discussing pretty patel the home
secretary she's in there uh what we
imagined she would be saying to the
prime minister so we knew she was in
there and we weren't sure about which
side she was going to fall onto because
she's an uber loyalist was she going to
be in the doris and jacob rees-mogg camp
but as i understand it following on from
datham at the times
i've been told that priti patel has
spoken to the prime minister this
evening where she's conveyed to him the
overwhelming views of the parliamentary
party we know what the overwhelming view
of the parties is that he should go so i
imagine what she has done and i imagine
she's done it quite reluctantly given
how supportive she is of him but she's
conveyed to him that the time is up that
the parliamentary party will not carry
his support i think she could be
different as a cabinet minister to
others i mean we know that delegation
that have gone in and no doubt uh
perhaps saying to the prime minister
either you go or we will walk out i
don't imagine pretty patel has
necessarily said that to the prime
minister maybe in the same way that
michael gove said i think it's time for
you to go without explicitly making a
threat on the back of that but this is
hugely significant pretty patel is an
absolute boris johnson die hard loyalist
that put him in to downing street back
in 2019 a key organizer
in the erg uh brexiteer campaign for the
brexit campaign again they are good
friends she was with him when he was
mayor campaigning for him in london so
for pretty patel to tell boris johnson
that the time is up that really is a
moment okay beth thank you very much
indeed let's talk to our colleague sam
kurtz deputy political editor in central
lobby in the houses of parliament and
talking there about the mood of the
parliamentary party that being
conveyed to the prime minister via
amongst others the home secretary tell
us about the conservative mps you've
been talking to islam
so i just had an update from as it were
the rebel camp the mps uh in parliament
now
their view is that they've done the
heavy lifting for today uh when you tot
up the resignations and you put them
together with uh conservative mps who've
restated their lack of confidence
in boris johnson you get to a figure
well over a hundred and that's the thing
that cabinet ministers have been going
in armed to downing street with that's
the thing uh that graham brady's gone
into downing street armed with uh and so
really
the rebels think that the action is
currently all behind closed doors over
downing street and with the prime
minister at the moment and i understand
from people talking actively to some of
the people uh in the conversations that
it's that threat from cabinet ministers
that they will resign if the prime
minister refuses to that means that this
is more likely than not to actually come
to a resolution to mean that everything
is forced to a resolution tonight there
hasn't been a resolution yet
but
according to the promises of the people
as they were going in to see the prime
minister either he goes or they goes so
if boris johnson tries to cling on then
suddenly he would be without a second
chancellor theoretically
for the second time in 24 hours he would
be out without a number of other high
profile
figures there would be huge gaps in his
cabinet it would look unsustainable and
at that point as he acknowledged to
liaison committee earlier today if you
can't govern then in those circumstances
he might actually be prepared to step
down but the rebels also say that in the
now less likely event that he manages to
cling on uh with whatever the cabinet
he's able to salvage behind him then it
will be on monday when they now fully
believe that the rules will be changed
so they can hold another place in no
confidence that vote will take place on
the cheese day and at that point he
would be out there is this sense there
needs to be an acceleration there is a
sense there is a discussion about what
would happen if boris johnson quit
suddenly creating a vacancy before a
leadership contest has resulted in a
name there are now tory mps talking
openly that dominic raav the depth prime
minister could once again step into that
gap the conversation demo has shifted so
much in 36 hours it's difficult to
describe but because of that dynamic of
cabinet ministers going into number 10
threatening to resign if he the prime
minister doesn't go himself that's the
thing that's making people start to
think that we are going to come to some
kind of resolution tonight
okay sam thank you very much elite tim
coats our deputy political editor with
the latest that he's hearing right in
the heart of parliament there that we
could hear something this very evening
let's get the views on that then with
the former government minister alastair
burt
who briefly had the conservative whip
removed in 2019 when he voted against mr
johnson's government over a no-deal
brexit and former foreign office
minister as well good to talk to
alistair but well uh no doubt you heard
sam coats there saying and you must be
picking up that feeling that it really
is over for mr johnson as prime minister
and it could happen as early as this
evening
yes i think that that's right things
have moved extraordinarily quickly but
in my experience that that is what
happens you can't plan these things i
remember
the
the end of mrs thatcher's a time as
prime minister the challenges against
john major in duncan smith and the like
and of course the concerted efforts to
remove theresa may by many of those who
have been supporting boris johnson these
things take on a life of their own
they're all slightly unpredictable but
there's a speed and there's a tipping
point that everyone seems to recognize
instinctively in parliament and that
seems to have happened over the last
24-36 hours
but if it's stability the party in the
country are after
are we going to get it then given the
number of people who would wish one
imagines to replace mr johnson
yes because the the the current threat
to stability is that there is a
government that is completely distracted
by the leadership issue
based around the personality and
character of boris johnson and it's
obvious that parliamentary colleagues
have come to a conclusion that
that instability
what appears to be a lack of focus on
the issues that really affect the nation
just cannot be settled as long as he's
there accordingly if the if that is
dealt with then of course there's a
period while the conservative party has
to decide who comes forward as the next
prime minister i heard what david howell
was saying i know there shouldn't be a
rush but it will need to be done
relatively speedily because there must
be a sense of direction for the country
and there must be a new prime minister
put in place as quickly and effectively
as possible
but you know what happens when the prime
minister is replaced mid-term then
the calls grow louder for some kind of
validation fairly soon through a general
election
yes but most new governments resist that
one way or another there's no
constitutional principle that requires
it
each new prime minister in those
circumstances know that they must get
validation in due course that's
absolutely correct but the timing is up
to them
um and i i think there's plenty of
precedent to say
what a new prime minister needs to do is
settle the country uh deliver uh make
good the sort of problems that have
removed a previous prime minister uh
there is only so long this government
has to go anyway the the election was in
2019. so it's not all that far away from
a general election in due course anyway
i hear the calls about mandate and
everything else all previous prime
ministers that have been replaced in
these circumstances have been through
that i think the most important thing
will be to recognize the country faces a
number of immediate storms and what is
happening abroad everyone is well aware
of the economic storms will get worse
the situation economically will be more
difficult come october as energy prices
rise and energy consumption increases
you will have the food issue the fuel
issue and i think at that stage number
one want to no one will want to throw a
general election into the middle of that
so let's see a new prime minister a new
government settle things down and then
there'll be a general election in due
course
but does a new leader heal the
conservative party you'll also have
heard lord howell talking about the the
rancor the poison that was injected into
the veins of the party 32 years ago with
the ejection of mrs thatcher that still
then has resonance today well boris
johnson won his vote of confidence 211
mps there even if that's now whittled
down a bit that's still a considerable
number of mps sitting there fuming
it is thurman it's a shrews observation
by david howell and a a good question
from you
i'm one of those who believes that if
the pri if margaret thatcher had stood
down after her 10 years if she had said
to the party i've done 10 years it's
time to go
the bitterness that was associated with
her removal just wouldn't have been
there you're right a spot that it could
be
that's why it would be right
for
prime minister boris johnson to
recognize tonight the strength of
feeling from his cabinet and go with
good grace
and not create a situation of bitterness
it would appear that the number of his
personal followers
are not necessarily huge in relation to
the party but there will be those who
will feel a strong personal attachment
and recognize his achievement in
relation to the last election but the
most important thing is to recognize
that things have moved on
and if the conservative party wishes to
offer a good challenge to the future
promote all the things that it believes
in and offer a good
choice to the british people then it
would be best to do it in some way
that's united
now the prime minister has a lot of
control over that depending on how you
leave that sets the tone for what is
going to happen that and those who have
supported him now people have to be
honest and remember that this prime
minister only became prime minister
because he and colleagues removed the
previous prime minister and people have
been able to let that go now his
followers must do the same it's only
fair so this is the approach that i
think would be best for him to take then
the party can
be as united as possible and then the
public and the nation because they are
more important than any party must then
have a choice as to what should be the
future
and i've got to ask you this also but
personally if boris johnson does go i
suspect you won't be shedding any
particular tears we we all know about
your open disagreements with him and
indeed that you felt he should never
have been prime minister in the first
place
yeah but i i think also
people like you and people in the
business know me well enough uh there's
no personal ranker at all
in a way this will be as always a
personal tragedy you know that the very
many of the factors that brought boris
johnson to be prime minister are also
responsible for his fall i have no
personal interest beyond that i was
disappointed and sorry not to continue
in the party because i couldn't accept
standing in an election where i had to
pledge to vote for something which i
couldn't do when i i resigned on
principle but i resigned with no
personal ranker in relation to the prime
minister uh and i wished him well now
it's not worked out because of things
that were were there in relation to how
he would govern the country the problems
of taking on a campaign team to run the
country a bit like a campaign in october
2019 it's not worked but i'm not one who
celebrates anybody's downfall what i
want to see is the best choice offered
to the british people at an election i
want to see a conservative party that's
successful i want my colleagues to do
well and i want the british people to
have a good choice it's not possible at
the moment with what has happened and
being out of it i've played no part in
this um but there's a number of
colleagues who left office and left
government in 2019
many of them i suspect are very keen to
play a part in any restoration of the
conservative party and the government if
the country wants that to happen so
we're keen to get involved and that's
really my only interest at present
something to be explored a later date
always good talking to you alastair burt
thank you so much for joining us on sky
news tonight let's bring you uh just
some of the latest pictures from around
here of course number 10 is a huge
government complex so we all focus on
this door but it's connected to the
cabinet office with many other entrances
and uh there's the brexit opportunities
minister leaving
that's might be the same time i've been
asking it it is not within my powers god
bless you thank you thank you so much
thank you
well jacob maurice-morgan you can see
yourself looking very chipper there
pausing for a word or two not saying
anything of substance but
with a smile on his face
just picking up every word he said uh
talked to him uh i talked to him last
night and he's been uh on the airways
quite a lot over the last 24 hours and
his position is is that the prime
minister shouldn't be going anywhere
because he's got a huge mandate 14
million people in an 80-seat majority
that we understand is not the view of
the
majority of the cabinet ministers in
there now talking to the prime minister
it's been a long day let's rewind to
about
12 o'clock this afternoon prime
minister's questions when mr johnson
faced mps for that regular session in
the house of commons and of course the
chris pincher scandal dominated
exchanges between him and the labour
leader sakia stammer our political
correspondent ali fortescue has been
analyzing what happened
it was an extraordinary pm cues mps
waited some wondered if he'd even show
up but as the prime minister arrived to
a solemn front bench eddie cheers were
very quickly drowned out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
starmar capitalized and the chamber was
silent as he asked his first question
relaying the details of an alleged
assault by chris pincher
he says
he grabbed my ass and then he slowly
moved his hand down in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister
just how serious the situation is
the pm tried to rally his side focus on
policy but it wasn't working
not least the 500 000 people we got off
welfare into work uh in the last six
months alone mr speaker those are things
that are making differences to the lives
of people up and down the country and
i'm proud of it
no one's cheering there
labour unimpressed but look at the pm's
own side their faces said it all
what a pathetic spectacle
the dying act of his political career is
to parrot that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
and if we look more closely at what was
going on on the tory benches sachin
javid arrived late to support from
rebels like mark harper but avoiding eye
contact with his old cabinet colleagues
missing from the front bench today was
housing secretary michael gove no word
yet on his position
the mood though was glum
this was pmq's in january jonathan
gullis cheering on the prime minister at
the height of partygate but look at him
today after resigning his junior role in
government last night elsewhere tory
back benchers used the opportunity to
have their say
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
resign today i asked him to do the
honorable thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
nothing um left for him to do other than
to take responsibility and resign
the prime minister's response here to
labour's ian lavery perhaps sums up the
tone
hang on in there mr speaker that's what
i'm going to do
and after pmq's came the scathing
statement from sajid javid who left the
chamber to pats on the back boris
johnson though couldn't have exited much
more quickly labour keen to bid him
farewell
[Music]
kirstama had a good pmqs but it was an
easy day to be leader of the opposition
mps behind the prime minister who
cheered him on through thick and thin
was solemn today the teflon prime
minister losing a grip on his own side
ali fortescue catching us up there on
prime ministers questions early today i
want to talk now to alex dina public
affairs consultant and former
conservative advisor
hello there alex
what do you think um the prime minister
is being told behind me in downing
street presumably being shown the red
card by some members of his cabinet
well that's what people have assumed
you're right but i've been careful about
assumptions particularly since the neil
parish incident when you will remember
many people were going around the
westminster village saying they knew for
a fact that mpx had looked at
pornography in the chamber and it wasn't
mpx i'm not going to second guess the
members of the cabinet who haven't
resigned who chose not to follow sati
javid and rishi sunak i'm going to wait
and see what they do
and i think reece smokes position
i just want to butt in there right
because i mean could you paint a
different scenario for us in to what's
happening there that perhaps they're
putting together a plan for boris
johnson to stay in place
well some will be arguing i don't know
whether they're in the building now or
not but some will definitely be telling
the prime minister to fight on that he
has loyalists within the party there are
some who will accept the argument that
you've heard uh offered earlier by jacob
rees-mogg that um boris johnson has an
enormous mandate that was
one relatively recently at the 2019
general election and some of those
people will be persuasive and seek to
say to boris our voters pos possibly
where it possibly were you being
defenestrated that's why they voted
conservative in the first place
why are these mps who owe their position
in the house to you going to be able to
overrule that and i think there's going
to be some force to that um so you i
think though that will be the
alternative perspective
so alex i mean do you not think though
that um the prime minister deserves to
go as so many in the party now think
because of his lack i suppose of um of
being honest with them particularly with
ministers you know we saw over the chris
pincher affair being sent out to say one
thing and then being contradicted a few
hours or indeed minutes later and uh it
happened before of course with owen
patterson
what you're talking about there is his
character i suppose and to my to me he's
showing grit right now he's showing
amazing grit in the face of challenges
like no prime minister in my lifetime
has faced and the kind of grit i want to
see in a pn and consider the runs of
prime minister that we've had margaret
thatcher tough as hell uh john major
surprisingly uh weak uh tony blair
beneath the charm very tough gordon
brown surprisingly uh glass jaw uh david
cameron uh beneath the suave and languid
nature very tough uh theresa may very
fragile you know it seemed to come one
after another and now we have boris
johnson extremely tough you know that's
part one dermot but the other part is
and this is more pragmatic you can't
beat somebody with nobody they're going
to have to have somebody they want to be
the spearhead of the attempt against
boris johnson and right now it seems
they haven't got it
well i just want to put you quickly uh
alex the the mass though here it comes
down to the 1922 committee and uh they
changed the rules there's another vote
then just look at their numbers they're
38 mps have resigned from the government
since yesterday let's imagine that they
didn't vote against him last time around
he got what 211 votes against 184 if
they switch sides or even abstain then
he loses in another vote of confidence
that's true but if you look at another
um perspective on the maths it's that
some of those 38 did vote against boris
johnson and given what they've said in
the media afterwards i would suggest
that there's some force to that some
people who were on the payroll vote
voted against the prime minister so they
didn't have confidence in him but in
that time being they hung on to their
jobs anyway which some people might
regard as the wrong thing for them to
have done if you look at the maths that
way you assume that you might be able to
get the members you want onto the 1922
committee then you assume that the 1922
committee votes the way you want and
then you assume that they want to have a
leadership contest and then you assume
the prime minister loses it and each one
of those assumptions are going to be
tested including the one which says
boris johnson might win a second
leadership contest
okay
alex what an interesting scenario you
paint alex dean there good talking to
you thank you very much indeed well
along the lines of that scenario we've
got some interesting information liz
bates our political correspondent is
here with me because uh sky source is uh
hearing uh
about the prime minister's mood about
the prime minister's well decision tell
us yes well we've had the latest on this
after everything that's happened today
we've seen cabinet ministers going in
and out of this building
urging him to sundown what we understand
is that the prime minister remains
defiant he is not going to stand down he
is going to continue imposed and try to
keep this government going and if you
think that is quite incredible to be in
that scenario where the prime minister
of the day is having to
confirm that he is going to stay in
office and that's purely because of all
of the things that we've seen building
up today we just saw him in prime
minister's questions that was a really
difficult moment for him lots of mps
sitting really glumly on the back bench
as well things have hugely deteriorated
since then we have the situation cabinet
ministers going in urging him to stand
down some of those cabinet ministers
some of the most supportive and loyal
people around him including people like
pretty patel also we understand that she
has decided
she has switched sides and said to him
with a heavy heart that it's time for
him to go that he can no longer carry on
even the chairman of the 1922 committee
sir graham brady is understood to be uh
preparing to advise him that he cannot
continue uh and should think about his
future and at the same time as that's
been happening over here we've had mps
across in parliament uh try discussing
whether they can change the rules to
force another vote of no confidence and
so he's been pushed and pushed it does
feel like the walls are closing in even
down at the gates here we can see
there's a wall of people it feels like
things are really closing in on the
prime minister and yet he is saying uh
this evening he remains defiant he will
carry on he still has a few supporters
we just saw jacob rees-mogg coming out
earlier we know nadine doris the culture
secretary that a very loyal portrait is
still on his side but they are really
dwindling at this point but he is
standing firm and not going anywhere
well i mean at the point i also put alex
dean as well about the 1922 committee
that looms then we you know
the backbench committee that organizes
votes of confidence nadine doris
[Music]
uh there we see uh the culture secretary
nadine dory's been in there so jacob
reese margus left grant schatz we saw
earlier has left the building and
nothing to say there obviously these
tense times but um this
let's add that to what we're hearing
about the prime minister's mood his
decision we hear that he's remaining to
fight and is intending to stay on and
i'm discussing that with liz bates here
and uh liz but then the 1922 committee
loots if it
has its elections to change the makeup
of the committee they allow another vote
to take place perhaps even with a higher
threshold
to trigger that with these 38
resignations so far you add those to 184
that already voted against him that's
more than enough to do it look the
feeling in westminster is that if they
can get to that position of having
another vote of no confidence so many
mps
have changed their minds since the last
one that there is really no way that he
could survive it doesn't mean that he
wouldn't uh attempt to do so but that is
really the the place that we're at at
the moment is that the discussion among
mps is not when he will go but how they
can force him out of office and um we've
seen cabinet ministers going in today uh
it was
suggested that if if
they spoke to him and said that his time
was up
then he may feel that he had to resign
if there's a a mass resignation of
cabinet ministers and he just simply
can't fill those posts he may then feel
that he has to resign but we know about
his character that he has survived many
scandals before and he often
hangs in there and feels that he can go
on so
it may be that it comes down to that
rule change the 1922 executive committee
and they'll be having those elections on
monday so it might be that we have to
wait a few more days so he decides to
buy some space and it was thought that
that perhaps was the situation last
night when he rapidly replaced the
chancellor and the health secretary but
then today of course the drip drip and
it was more than a drip drip let's call
it a deluge of ministerial resignations
and pps's
if that doesn't happen tomorrow will he
feel that he can at least get to the
weekend and then regroup
i think that's possible and again i
think this is what we've seen from him
time and time again he just feels that
if he can get through the next hour
through the next day he can figure out a
plan and hang in there and uh and
continue in the role that he that he
loves and he there's no question that he
wants to continue as prime minister i
think it's interesting talking about
yesterday because what we've seen is the
real fluctuations in westminster when
those first two resignations came those
big resignations the health secretary
and the chancellor the the feeling uh
from many conservative mps that i spoke
to was that he had a matter of hours
left after that and we were going to see
many many more cabinet
resignations it did seem like he was
regrouping last night and um he
appointed a new chancellor nadeem zahawi
he promoted michelle donald well what we
hear today is after that drip drip
effect of resignations
they have now gone after being promoted
yesterday and joined that uh team of uh
cabinet ministers we understand who are
suggesting to him that he needs to go so
it just shows how quickly things can
change in a matter of 24 hours but on
that that we hear the prime minister is
defiant well you know he hasn't actually
changed his tune then from during the
course of the day he's been out and
about a lot in the public eye for such a
long time uh the prime minister's
questions where he made it very clear he
was going to carry on and then the
bruising session at the liaison
committee where he made it very very
clear he continues absolutely and it's
quite um
amazing really to watch how he uh
performed in pmq's and in front of the
liaison committee given everything
that's going on absolutely defiant in
his manner quite interesting at the
liaison committee you know he's been
asked questions
about policy and government departments
as uh ministers from those departments
were resigning there was even somebody
on the committee hugh maryman who was
tweeting a statement to say that the
prime minister should resign as that
committee was going on so it's an
incredible spectacle but yeah as i say
at this point he remains defiant he will
stay on as long as he can okay and that
is the latest we're taking a short break
now those latest we're hearing from here
live in downey street the prime minister
is defiant and will not resign stay with
us for continuing coverage
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's eight o'clock this is sky news
tonight with me dermot murder and the
top story live from downing street where
boris johnson's premiership hangs in the
balance
tonight he faces a delegation of cabinet
colleagues some of them calling for him
to step down as leader and of course as
prime minister
amongst them is new chancellor nadeem
zahawi after 24 hours in the role
but mr johnson is apparently adamant
that he'll stay the course despite a
bruising day of questioning from
in committee and the house of commons
spreading the tightrope between loyalty
and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i'm not going to give her a running
commentary on political events and we're
going to get on with the government of
the country
so the prime minister's future now rests
with the influential committee of
conservative back bench mps the 1922
committee it's been meeting during the
day
[Music]
a very good evening live from downing
street where for a second night the
prime minister is fighting for his
political survival having faced 38
government resignations today he tonight
faced a delegation of cabinet ministers
who are calling for him to resign now we
await what mr johnson has to say after
that meeting but number 10 sources are
saying tonight that he will not stand
down
well earlier a prime minister's
questions this lunch time he insisted he
plans to hang on in there and keep going
he then faced a two-hour session with
all the chairs of commons committees at
the powerful liaison committee there mr
johnson said he could not see why he
should resign when questioned by
labour's darren jones
it's not brave for you to carry on doing
this i think in my view you're hurting
the country prime minister
just on a very human level surely you
must know that it's in the country's
interest for you to leave now isn't it i
i look i i think that the country is
going through tough times and i think
that we have the
uh the biggest
you know you're making a a point about
about duty right yeah and uh i i look at
the uh the issues that this country
faces i look at the um
the pressures that people uh are under
and the need for government to focus on
that on
on their priorities uh which is what we
are doing i look at
the biggest war in europe for 80 years
and
i cannot for the life of me uh see or
how it is responsible just to to walk
away from that as i said earlier on in
uh in pmq's particularly not when you
have a mandate of the kind that
we won
two three years ago
that was mr johnson early this afternoon
well resignations continued this evening
so let's look at the latest state of
play and uh these are the
numbers and some of the people involved
the uh since the resignation of the
chancellor and the health secretary last
night there's been a deluge of
conservative mps handing in their
letters of resignation the total now
stands at 38 and another tory mp we
understand is threatening to resign if
mr johnson doesn't step down
chief among them the former health
secretary sajid javid of course his
resignation last night and he made a
statement in the house of commons today
explaining his reasons for resigning
the tight rope between loyalty and
integrity has become impossible in
recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up
it's not fair on my parliamentary
colleagues who bear the brunt of
constituents dismay in their inboxes and
on their doorsteps in recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white olive friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue gray report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
the former health secretary sajid chavi
there explaining his reasons for
resigning from the government last night
let's uh check in with our chief
political correspondent john craig in
central lobby there in the houses of
parliament and uh john where are all
trying to work out what might be going
on behind me here in number 10.
well here in parliament i can tell you
that mps are aghast at the reports we're
hearing that the prime minister has told
his cabinet colleagues i'm not quitting
now i can tell you that that is indeed
the case because i've just been it's
just been reported to me that the
ministers who went in to see the prime
minister said to him you've got to go
prime minister and they said to him no i
am not going well they were aghast i've
just been talking to one of the
ministers who resigned today she said no
but i can tell you i have it on very
good authority that the prime minister
from a senior mp
that the prime minister has told cabinet
colleagues he will not quit now to
assess that i am joined by
the leader westminster leader of the
scottish national party ian blackford
what do you make of the fact that pm's
refusing to go well knowing the
character of the man i suppose i'm not
surprised but you know we have to say to
boris johnson he's not a dictator
he's there in power because he's put in
by the
the public of course at the election but
he is only there with the confidence of
the mps that serve in this parliament it
doesn't have the confidence of his own
party he doesn't have the confidence of
his own cabinet if he had any decency
any self-respect any dignity he would
realize that for him this is over he
will be dragged out next week because
the tory party will make sure the 1922
committee changed the rules they can
have a motion of no confidence this is a
man that just about universally
parliament wants gone he cannot stay in
office but he needs to show some
self-sacrifice he needs to realise for
him he should have been gone by now and
to dig his heels in when his own cabinet
have turned against him my goodness this
is unprecedented
but he's been arguing today both at
prime minister's questions when you had
your usual weekly joust with him
and also upstairs at the liaison
committee
that
he's got a mandate he was elected in
2019 with a majority of 80. he claims
he's got a mandate from the public he's
broken the trust that was put into him
in that election campaign mps are acting
in the interest of their constituents
knowing that this man is now unpopular
to such an extent a man that we know
that has misled parliament has lied has
cheated he's lied again and put
ministers in impossible situations this
week for him it's over and for him to
try and cling on desperately to cling on
this simply wouldn't work parliament
will do its job and the fact that he is
showing no dignity in his final hours in
his final days really speaks about the
contempt that this man has for
parliament this is not his personal play
thing this is a man let's not forget
that illegally shut down parliament the
corrugation of parliament once again
he's trying to cling on but quite
frankly he's left with very few friends
in this place you say parliament will
have its say but the fact is he's still
uh even after a few by-election defeats
got a pretty big majority uh there's
nothing you as opposition parties can do
is there let's wait and see and i think
first well i think first and foremost
what has to happen is conservative mps
have got to take their own
responsibility within their hands they
can do that through the 1922 committee
now normally it would be the case that a
motion of no confidence would have no
chance of success because tory mps
would vote with the government would
vote with the prime minister this is
fracturing to such an extent that there
is that option if anyone else fails the
emotional no confidence might be the
only way that we can get rid of this
prime minister for my message to tory
mps on monday they have got to do that
job they have got to make sure that they
pass a motion of no confidence in them
let's get this man this besmirch the
office of prime minister
out the door if he's not going to do it
then he needs to be dragged screaming
and kicking out of the door but i think
i'm right he's saying that a motion of
no confidence on the floor of the house
that motion has to come from the leader
of the official opposition doesn't it it
would have to come from the leader of
the official opposition to be taken
that's absolutely correct but let's make
sure tory mps take their
responsibilities next monday when they
have the 1922 committee and that they
make sure that there's a motion of no
confidence the house has to speak with a
very clear voice this man has to go
your colleague from the flight company
today in the commons said
that he was the the prime minister the
current prime minister was the best
recruiting sergeant for independence of
i assume she meant wales and scotland um
secretly
we all know that you and he get on quite
well across the commons chamber there
you probably want him to stay because
you think he's good for the cause of
independence probably i actually have no
relationship with the prime minister i
want him gone and we will win
independence on the basis of the appeal
that we put to the people in scotland
about how we deliver a greener economy
one that can deliver sustainable
economic growth and fairness we don't
need boris johnson to do that we will do
that but in the meantime this man is a
danger to democracy he has to be gone
okay ian blackford thank you very much
well that's the view of ian blackford
the uh
the leader of the snp here at
westminster who denies that he's chummy
with the prime minister despite all the
grinning across the dispatch box we see
it prime minister's questions on a
wednesday just to confirm i have had it
confirmed to me by a very senior member
of parliament here
that when cabinet ministers went in to
see the prime minister and told him the
game's up he had to go he told them no i
am not going that's the latest from here
and uh ministers and opposition mps are
aghast at that news as we just heard
from ian
blackford okay john thank you very much
john craig there our chief political
correspondent in the hearts of houses of
parliament there and let's uh follow on
from that then if the prime minister is
defiant refusing to go
with no prospective resignation then
from him his future now could rest
almost entirely with the backbench 1922
committee that's the influential
committee of mps which you'll remember
ran that vote of confidence in him just
a few weeks ago let's uh take you
through precisely their role now this is
what they do formally every week when
the house of commons is sitting they
meet to set the rules of the party
it
marshall's votes of confidence in the
leader after facing one of those votes
last month mr johnson is safe from
another for a year those are the
existing rules but now elections are
underway to change key members of the
committee candidates including the likes
of steve baker and andrew bridge and no
fans of the prime minister who have
suggested they would then change the
rules if elected to allow another vote
of confidence much earlier than that
12-month deadline nominations for these
executive members are open right now
they close
on monday afternoon with results
later that evening so that's next monday
and after the election results the
committee can discuss any potential rule
changes could happen very quickly that
means boris johnson could face another
confidence vote within days maybe weeks
however any vote would need to take
place before parliament goes on summer
recess in just over two weeks time or
then it would have to be delayed until
the
parliament reconvenes in september well
our westminster correspondent liz bates
joins me now um pointing out there the
role of the 1922 committee so it may
well come into play if as we understand
we're hearing it john craig heard it
there in the house of commons we're
hearing it from our sources as well here
in downing street that the prime
minister is defiant and said to those
cabinet members who said you should go
prime minister he said no i'm not
absolutely that's what we're hearing
tonight that even after everything
that's happened today his own cabinet
ministers confronting him uh in downing
street and saying your time is up he
remains defiant he's not going to resign
he
fights on if you like what he's going to
have to start doing as well is start to
fill those positions those government
positions because we're still seeing
that drip drip
of people resigning but it does seem
like at this point after everything
that's happened his position is you are
going to have to drag me out of office
kicking and screaming and that may very
well be what happens and one of the only
mechanisms one of the only processes
that they have is a vote of no
confidence so it may be that it comes
down to the 1922 executive committee to
as you've just outlined changed the
rules at that point there will have to
be another vote of no confidence we
assume at this point because of the way
that the tide has turned against the
prime minister here in westminster so
many of his mps many supportive of him
uh over years have turned against him
and just believed that he he cannot
carry on it does seem at this point like
he would lose that vote but time and
again what we see from boris johnson is
he uh often at very difficult moments
when he seems to have lost support when
it seems like his premiership is coming
to an end he will try to hang on just
for another few hours another few days
and what he will be looking
at now is if those 1922 elections are
going to happen on monday that buys him
a little bit more time maybe he can
appoint some more ministers uh rally the
troops and maybe he can survive a little
bit longer that's what he will be
thinking about several lifts aren't
there about the elections themselves and
the nature and character of the mps that
are elected on to that committee the new
members and indeed a rule change because
even those mps that are opposed to the
prime minister have asked for him to go
or resign from his government are a
little squeamish about changing the
rules of the 1922 committee because they
say then well okay in these
circumstances we want to do that to
remove this prime minister but then if
they stay in place then every leader of
the party could face almost perpetual
challenges
absolutely and you're right to put it
like that because they are quite squishy
about that they are quite protective
of those rules and the etiquette that
they've had to govern the party over
many years i just think that many uh mps
uh
not just people that have been critical
of boris johnson but even some of his
supporters are feeling like if he won't
go it is just too detrimental for the
party uh to let him continue especially
with the government in his complete
state of paralysis you know the
country's also facing a cost of living
crisis that we've completely forgotten
about as well and i think there's
there's such a strength of feeling
within the conservative party that they
may well decide they want to hold their
noses and change the rules but as you
say it will depend on who is elected uh
to the executive committee and if they
are
prepared to push through with this i
mean things can change very quickly so
we'll have to see if that goes ahead
what about what's going on in there now
so we are imagining of course that um
cabinet members not all of them of
course but cabinet members went in and
said mr johnson we think you should
we're asking you to resign as leader and
as prime minister he's defiant saying no
i will not go well then isn't that back
to those cabinet members and they should
resign
absolutely well where does that where
does that leave them i mean it's quite
interesting we just saw um you pointed
out nadine doris uh coming out as
supporter of the prime minister we saw
jacob rees-mogg both looking happy it
was a show i think of defiance they are
some of those uh supporters that are
still hanging in there remaining loyal
to the prime minister but
many other cabinet ministers going in
there to confront him and saying you
cannot carry on as prime minister well
how can they then carry on in their
cabinet post so something that we may
see is resignations this evening if the
talks behind those doors have gone the
way that we think they have yeah and the
significance of these what 38
resignations in total the majority of
them taking place during the course of
the day and these are not the the front
rank this is ministers and pps's as
they're called and many of them the the
the younger members of the parliamentary
party the intake from just a couple of
years ago and and the election before
that
yes absolutely so that shows i mean i
think what we've seen really over the
past few days is there is no faction
here that's turned against the prime
minister there are many uh mps from
different intakes different sides of the
conservative party with very different
loyalties and
that raises questions of course where
that leaves the party uh when this all
kind of blows up but what i think that
shows is that this isn't a kind of
concerted move by any one particular
group it's a lot of um maybe small
groups and individual mps feeling that
it's a matter of conscience that they
have to
stand down but as you say the thing to
watch this evening is those cabinet mist
as many of them still remain in post
having said to the prime minister we
don't believe that you should be leading
this country anymore so there was a
suggestion earlier that there may be a
kind of mass resignation
from them in a kind of final
attempt to
push him into resigning but it doesn't
seem like he has any plans to do that
what's a fascinating knife ed situation
we are in uh despite thank you very much
indeed for the time being we're taking a
short break and you're watching sky news
tonight live from the heart of downey
street coming up next we'll have the
latest from today's fractious prime
minister's questions and look ahead to
tomorrow's action in the house of
commons
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm sky's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old and sir cool
ass just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against that the
wind is the really big problems it is
back breaking work and the smoke is
thick
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
change seems tantalizingly close in this
corner of the uk
wales was the first to introduce the
plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
now then boris johnson faced mps in the
house of commons today at prime
minister's questions the chris pincher
scandal dominated exchanges between him
and the labour leader sakia stama our
political correspondent ali fortescue
has been analyzing what happened
it was an extraordinary pmq's mps waited
some wondered if he'd even show up but
as the prime minister arrived to a
solemn front bench eddie cheers were
very quickly drowned out
[Music]
and the chamber was silent as he asked
his first question relaying the details
of an alleged assault by chris pincher
he says
he grabbed my ass and then he slowly
moved his hand down in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister
just how serious the situation is
the pm tried to rally his side focus on
policy but it wasn't working
not least the 500 000 people we got off
welfare into work uh in the last six
months alone mr speaker those are things
that are making differences to the lives
of people up and down the country and
i'm proud of it
no one's fearing that
labor unimpressed but look at the pm's
own side their faces said it all
what a pathetic spectacle the the dying
act of his political career is to parrot
that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
and if we look more closely at what was
going on on the tory benches sachit
javid arrived late to support from
rebels like mark harper but avoiding eye
contact with his old cabinet colleagues
missing from the front bench today was
housing secretary michael gove no word
yet on his position the mood though was
glum
this was pmq's in january jonathan
gullis cheering on the prime minister at
the height of partygate but look at him
today after resigning his junior role in
government last night elsewhere tory
backbenchers used the opportunity to
have their say
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
resign today i ask him to do the
honorable thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
nothing
left for him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
the prime minister's response here to
labour's ian lavery perhaps sums up the
tone hang on in there mr speaker that's
what i'm going to do
and after pmq's came the scathing
statement from sajid javid who left the
chamber to pats on the back boris
johnson though couldn't have exited much
more quickly labour keen to bid him
farewell
[Music]
kirsten had a good pm keys but it was an
easy day to be leader of the opposition
mps behind the prime minister who
cheered him on through thick and thin
was solemn today the teflon prime
minister losing a grip on his own side
ali fortescue and how the political
winds have changed so dramatically for
the prime minister let's talk to our
chief political correspondent john craig
he's in central lobby in the houses of
parliament uh sniffing the
wind metaphorically for us there john
what are you hearing
well as shock at the news that the prime
minister has told his cabinet he's not
quitting and there's also some concern
about the commons business tomorrow i
can tell you dermot because it's dcms
questions culture media sport of course
uh nadine doris the the ultimate i
suppose uh
johnson loyalist is still there but one
of her junior ministers julia lopez has
gone it's then attorney general's
questions now sweller bravo man is still
there but the solicitor general alex
chalk has gone so we're going to see
a pretty sparsely attended government
front bench tomorrow by all accounts um
fortunately for the government the main
business of the day is back bench
business
so probably not too many front benches
required for that but there is shock
here i can tell you amongst tories one
minister said no when i said he's
refusing to go another minister has just
said to me when i told him the news um
well we'll see how long that holds so uh
some feeling that perhaps uh be a change
overnight perhaps when the prime
minister slept on it he might think
again let's get a labour reaction we've
heard from the snp joined by steve reed
the shadow justice secretary what do you
make of the news that the pm has told
his cabinet colleagues he's not going to
go well it's staggering given the
circumstances he's he is the bad smell
that just won't go away now and he's
lost so much support he's lost so much
support in the country leave alone leave
alone in his own party in parliament but
for a prime minister to cling on when
he's actually now damaging the good
government of our country the government
is frozen we have whole departments like
education now that are bereft
of ministers decisions are not being
taken decisions about kids futures
in in those cases but that applies to
every single part of government now that
man has become a block he's putting his
own personal ambition his own
self-delusion ahead of the interest of
the british people and what i want to
see happen next is those members of the
cabinet who have not resigned which is
actually all of them except too they
need to get in there
publicly quit their jobs now and force
that man out of office so that we can
get this country back on track again
well they've gone to him quite a few of
them a delegation um
all said to him prime minister you've
got to go and he's just told him to go
away no i'm got not going well there's a
nice way to do this and there's a nasty
way to do this and if the man won't
agree to walk out the door he has to be
dragged he has to be dragged out of the
door i mean i it staggers me that it's
taken so many of them this long to
realize quite what he is by his behavior
right now he's showing again his
contempt for the country of which he is
the prime minister and for the british
people as he did with his lockdown
parties uh during during while the
british people were making incredible
sacrifices he was allowing uh suitcases
of booze to be wheeled into number 10
downing street that same attitude of
contempt towards the british people they
should have acted then they need to act
now and that means resigning on mass
from the cabinet to get that man out one
thing you could do as the official
opposition is to put down a motion of no
confidence in the prime minister it has
to be the leader of the official
opposition that does that will saqir
stama do that well there will be there
will be conversations going on with the
whip so i'm pretty sure if this uh if
the prime minister refuses to go because
he does have to be removed now he is he
is he is a blockage to the good
government of our country he needs to
get out of office and if he won't go
willingly he will be dragged kicking and
screaming one way or another out of
office but come on you can surely you
can tell me that zakir stama will put
down a motion of no confidence if
necessary of my pay grade to tell my
boss come on you're a member of the
shadow cabinet that is going to do but i
would
if if it needs to come to that it will
come to that and it will be a
negotiation across the parties and with
those members of the conservative party
who are finally seeing what the rest of
us have seen for years this man is unfit
for office and needs to be kicked out
sounds though sake is being a bit
cautious here you just said you have to
you have to have discussion with mps of
other parties including the
conservatives why not be bold this is a
put down a motion of no confidence this
is a psycho drama inside the
conservative party and we need to make
we need to see if they can find the
backbones they've been missing for these
past few years and get rid of a leader
who is now a threat to the good
government of our country if they can't
do it then i'm sure parliament will come
together and see what we can all do
when you say parliament come together
emotion no confidence well if that will
be certainly one of the most obvious
options on the table it's not just for
me to say this on your show i don't wish
to be rude but there will be
conversations involving a lot of people
to get that okay steve reed thank you
very much well there you have it um it
sounds as though a motion of no
confidence put forward by the official
opposition
is something that's being considered uh
we await news from sir kia starmer of
whether he's going to do that but uh
steve reed thank you very much that's
steve reid the
shadow justice secretary reacting for
labor
real shock here um there's not enormous
number of mps around i can tell you the
commons and the lords have now risen
um so
there are still some mps here there is a
mood of disbelief let me just let me
just confirm to you what i heard a short
time ago from a very senior member of
the house of commons that when the
cabinet ministers went in including
loyalists to tell the prime minister
including people like pretty patel the
game's up prime minister you've got to
go he sent them away and said no i am
not quitting i have that on very highest
authority here in the house of commons
and uh that is what happened in the room
so the prime minister said no i'm not
quitting and now we've got labour
considering putting down a motion of no
confidence that we've already spoken to
the snp they would obviously support
that
so
things now obviously will continue to
move at a fast pace i should also say
excuse me i've just spoken to one
government minister still in his job a
minister of state who said to me uh when
i told him what the prime minister's
reaction was well let's see if that
holds so there may be a change of course
overnight may well be that the prime
minister changes his mind overnight
and in the morning um of course margaret
thatcher famously said we fade fight on
we fight to win and then of course she
bowed out and uh in some ways it's
similar to november 1990 except that
night i remember
the cabinet ministers all went into
margaret thatcher's room here in the
commons one by one this time they all
went to see boris johnson in downing
street and they were all in the room
together so a bit different but similar
sort of picture really where you've got
the cabinet turning on a prime minister
john craig there with a glimpse of the
opening chapter of his memoirs thank you
very much indeed john
and you're watching sky news tonight
live from downey street coming up next
we'll get an idea what might be going on
behind that door tonight for meetings we
know with someone who's been on the
inside
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news live in downing
street where we understand cabinet
members of being inside behind that door
for the last two or three hours or so
talking some of them advising the prime
minister telling the prime minister to
step down let's get the latest with our
westminster correspondent liz bates and
we understand that when that has been
put to the prime minister the prime
minister is the word is defiant
that's what we've been told that the
prime minister is going nowhere he will
fight on basically he will have to be
dragged out of this building kicking and
screaming and that might that is what
the conservative party is thinking about
how they can do um what how they can do
that basically uh at the moment the
question now i think is what we've seen
over the past few hours we're basically
in a bit of no man's land now we've had
a big chunk of the cabinet going to the
prime minister confronting him saying we
don't believe in your leadership anymore
and he has said
basically get lost i'm going to carry on
and so where does that now leave those
cabinet ministers because they now i
think
either have to resign or they have to
very much change their tune and come out
publicly and say okay i'm going to
now back the prime minister after
everything that's happened today and
start to put together policies in a
programme of government and go on tv and
do all the kinds of um interviews that
we've seen before in which they uh back
this prime minister so they're really in
a difficult position we're going to be
watching over the next few hours what
those people are saying let's do some uh
let me call it downing streetology of
what we've seen in the comings and
goings i said we understand that the
majority of the cabinet
are still in there now they may have
left by different routes there are so
many ways in and out but the ones we've
seen publicly demonstrably leaving are
the uber loyalists jacob rees-mogg
nadine doris grant chaps are they
sending a message out
i think they absolutely are sending a
message out no question of that we saw
earlier nadine doris uh come out of the
front door she was smiling jacob smog
the same thing both of them
saying that they will be standing by the
prime minister
come what may what we haven't seen is
those other cabinet ministers and what's
quite interesting is i'm starting to see
and this is often what happens at
moments like this in westminster
conflicting briefings uh now coming out
on uh social media some suggesting that
nadeem zahawi and pretty patel uh
never confronted the prime minister and
uh never turned against him and that
they're happy to stay on his cabinet and
they were always on his side um which is
slightly uh bizarre and this is
something that we need to get to the
bottom of the bottom but that really
gets to the heart of where does that
leave
his cabinet now
if he really wants to
continue as prime minister
uh boris johnson is going to have to
start filling those empty seats um of
those positions in government all the
resignations that have happened today
he's going to have to start looking
around the party and find people that
are willing now to step up and serve in
a government after all of the turmoil
that we've been through over the past
year even with an atc majority i mean
you you eventually run out of people 38
resignations in the last 24 hours you
certainly do and i think speaking to
conservative mps over the past few days
i think it's likely that he will start
to run out of people but there's no
question there are still supporters of
boris johnson uh within the party and
from what we hear from him tonight he
believes
that he can carry on and he will not be
forced into resigning by people going
into his office and telling him they've
lost confidence him he will have to be
removed by his mps and that's why many
people are turning their attentions now
to the 1922 committee to see if they can
bring different people into the
executive committee and to change the
rules and that may we that may be the
only way that they can get boris johnson
because it seems like this pressure this
political pressure that's been building
and we've seen this type of thing out of
prime ministers before it seems like
boris johnson is digging in he's not
having any just tell us about the 1922
committee how soon that could happen
certainly not this side of the weekend
it does seem like uh it could drag on
they met today to discuss a rule change
there's no question that many
conservative mps are happy uh to push
ahead with a rule change but they will
have to elect a new executive committee
those elections will start on monday at
that point the process will get underway
for trying to change the rules and it
could it could go on for longer and that
will make the prime minister feel
positive that he has a bit more time in
office time to regroup try time to make
new appointments and uh hopefully uh
from his position he'll want to stay on
okay liz for the time being thank you
very much indeed uh keep listening keep
the
research going well our deputy political
editor sam coats has been reporting
today that according to one of boris
johnson's allies he would rather be
dragged out of downing street than
resigned as we've been saying in his own
accord that work defiant because he
prefers the optics so in these
fast-moving febrile towns in westminster
uh just what is it like behind the
scenes in the building behind me well uh
it's speculation of course but we can
get the views of those in the know
joining me is kevin craig chief
executive and founder of the
communications agency at plmr and henry
hill deputy editor of conservative home
good to talk to you both uh henry let's
get your view first and uh we all of us
are wondering what might be going on
behind those doors we understand that
the cabinet the might of the cabinets
are there many of them saying prime
minister time to go
well i think the absolutely fascinating
question is going to be what do you do
if you're one of the cabinet ministers
who didn't resign who went to the prime
minister today and told him that he
needed to resign
and then he refuses because you're in an
impossible position you can't really
continue doing your job you've expressed
no confidence in the prime minister you
will be hounded about it in parliament
you'll be hounded about it every time
you do the news round so really you need
to resign but what we're hearing instead
is the report as your reporter said is
we're now getting these conflicting
reports where it seems that some people
who might have told the prime minister
he needs to go are starting to backpedal
now compared to the the conservative
party that ruthlessly defenestrated
margaret thatcher back in the day
uh there has been this sort of lack of
ruthlessness on the part of modern
conservative mps they limped over the
line in a very chaotic way to that first
no confidence balance a few weeks ago
they've now sort of limped their way to
this latest crisis with two resignations
and it's really unfortunate i think that
given that this government is circling
the drain i think at this point boris
johnson couldn't even appoint his
preferred candidate as chancellor that
they're making such a spectacle of it
and taking so long to do it when i think
a clean break and decisive action would
be much better for the party and the
country
clearly not happening though uh kevin
craig is it um i mean what do you make
of that has been said that boris johnson
would prefer something of a scorched
earth policy
that's absolutely right i mean we've
been talking to clients all throughout
the day about what happens next and the
key here is boris johnson his psychology
why on earth would he listen to any of
these pleas to go if you follow the
career of the man and those around him
he sees it very clearly we saw it today
with conor burns we've got a lot of
stick the northern ireland minister lots
of stick on social media but there is
the heart of the prime minister's
approach i won this election you're not
going to kick me out and actually i will
i will leave it to you i'm not going
anywhere i've got a direct connection
with the british public and i i don't
see why i should leave and i'm not
playing by your rules and every day this
goes on it's an absolute gift for the
labour party the house of commons was
savage today absolutely savage but boris
johnson is not a typical politician he
is not going to come out here before
midnight i make a sober i'm sorry
statement it's just not happening so
we're nowhere near finished yet
okay uh henry hill we're just here and
i'm sure you've already heard it that uh
another pps is gone jacob young the uh
leveling up pbs so i think that makes it
39 in total we'll update our little
ticker uh so henry hill i mean we're
talking about uh boris johnson doesn't
obey the rules but presumably there are
some rules party rules that he does have
to obey and i'm talking of course about
the 1922 committee now he survived a
vote of confidence four or five weeks
ago the
presumption is given what's happened in
the last few days he wouldn't survive
another one they just have to change the
rules to allow one to take place do you
think that is going to happen
uh almost certainly they've moved they
didn't decide to do it today but they
have moved forward the elections for a
new executive for the 1922 committee
which is going to take place on monday
it's almost certain that boris johnson's
opponents will walk those elections and
then they will control whether or not
the 22 changes its internal rules which
they're completely free to do there has
been some really deranged stuff from
some of the prime minister's supporters
about mass withdrawing the whip from
every mp that votes against him you know
i i'm not actually entirely sure that he
couldn't do that in theory um as party
leader but i don't think it would wash i
think at that point you know the great
majority of conservative mps outside his
bunker would just reject that as a
complete use of patient of his rightful
authority as leader but yes i think at
the point where he a majority of his own
mps have declared they have no
confidence in his leadership i don't
actually think you know this threat he
has to go to the country i don't think
he'd be able to do it because he would
no longer obviously command the
confidence of the house of commons that
might put the queen in a difficult
position but yes ultimately if he can't
staff his cabinet and if a majority of
conservative mps say they don't have any
confidence in him as party leader the
game is up you simply can't run a
government based on a small number of
loyalists alone you need to have the
votes to pass legislation and you need
to have the bodies to fill out the
payroll vote all those pps positions
trade envoys and all the rest of it and
if you don't have them
the jig is over
yeah we're just uh showing that uh news
that i reported earlier that um jacob
young has resigned as the leveling up
pbs and there's the tweet confirming it
so kevin craig your your thoughts on the
1922 committee there are those mps who
say well you know even though we're
against mr johnson we shouldn't really
be moving the the goal posts on that
i i think there's that there is a risk
that there's a growing band of opinion
that thinks the conservative party might
come across as quite undemocratic if it
removes the prime minister in this way
and i think that the longer it goes on
the more chance that boris johnson has
got to circle his wagons and survive
again and the 1922 is of course
important the chairman was in today
giving wise counsel we heard but
ultimately
the prime minister and those around him
think he has a mandate and they are
going to make the other side
see this through and no matter how
brutal that is how damaging for the
conservative party we heard 69 the
country you know against the prime
minister by elections being lost all
over the place but they are going to
push it you know boris johnson is not
going to do what they ask and the
question is how much political damage
how permanent that is is going to be
done to the conservative party in the
meantime
yeah well that's a very good point kevin
craig makes isn't it henry hill you know
i was talking to lord howell earlier who
was around for the the defenestration of
margaret thatcher and he said of course
and we all know it that some of the
poison from that ran through the veins
and still run through runs through the
veins of the conservative party the
longer it goes on the more lasting
damage it causes to an extent i think
there's a danger of that especially
amongst the grass roots where the prime
minister does have a committed block of
supporters but amongst the parliamentary
party i think it's much sort of an issue
there have never been johnsonite that's
been one of the features of his
premiership he has a handful of these
people who are personally loyal to him
but margaret thatcher had a big block of
mps who were ideologically committed to
her project and she'd earned their
loyalty over 10 years of
transformational government and winning
three general elections boris johnson
simply hasn't done that he hasn't done
the the policy leg work all the time in
parliament to build up that kind of
block so i think it's it's much less a
danger than it was in margaret
thatcher's case
and kevin craig just on this issue of
the prime minister going of course it's
been discussed for at least the last six
months and one of the issues perhaps
staying the hand of those that have
doubts within the party about the prime
minister is this issue of a kind of
standout replacement they need stability
the country needs stability as quickly
as possible if the prime minister goes a
leadership election we could see well
what over a dozen candidates at the very
least
yeah and there is no there is no
standout candidate um and the uh new
leader would then have years of being uh
faced with the labour party quite
rightly saying what's your mandate and
why are you here and who elected you and
it's enough of this internal
conservative party nonsense we demand a
general election so i i think again
you know it's not my politics but if
you're thinking about the survival of
what's best for the conservative party i
think there'll be quite a lot of them
tonight thinking do we really want to do
this do we know what's going to happen
next do we know who the replacement is
they don't know any of this and they
also don't know what is the big picture
conversation that's going to define
british politics and who do they think
is going to beat kierstama because that
man is riding high and loving every
second of this
yeah yeah well that's another issue
isn't it uh depending if he's still
there after uh durham constabulary's
decision which we are expecting perhaps
this week as well uh what extraordinary
times we're in kevin craig henry hill
very good to talk to you about thank you
very much indeed for your thoughts so
let's catch up on what we're hearing
from inside that building behind me our
westminster correspondent liz bates
joins me now what they're hearing inside
there as well there's been another
resignation we've updated uh what we
call our ticker at the bottom of the
screen 39 resignations now in just over
24 hours this the uh
parliamentary private secretary leveling
up uh jacob young has resigned can't
take it anymore yes we hadn't had one
for a bit had we so we've got another
resignation there and as you said we've
been seeing those um
trickle in throughout the day quite
interesting what he said in his
resignation was that he'd agonized about
this decision and as a supporter of the
prime minister he just feels like he
wants
the best for him and just feels like he
doesn't see his future as as tenable
anymore so
quite clearly the prime minister it's
not just his critics at this point that
are resigning that's suggesting to him
that his time is up it's even people
that have supported him some of his
closest allies uh we believe um are now
feeling that he just cannot continue on
in this role so a really difficult
situation
let's just examine that i mean it's a
real mishmash isn't it reasons of course
front and center is the prime minister's
character in this charge that he's been
misleading them in particular misleading
ministers and putting them out there to
bat on his behalf without telling them
the full facts but there's also isn't
there bubbling away within the party a
semi-ideological discussion about this
government this prime minister not being
conservative enough in his policies
absolutely i think there's uh concern uh
on that issue on uh there are many mps
that uh feel that the prime minister
just hasn't been uh
forceful enough in pushing through uh
certain policies there is there is of
course also uh the issue of his
character this idea uh that he has a a
a particularly unique relationship with
the truth and uh one of the things that
we hear sadly javi speaking about uh in
the chamber today we've heard this from
many other ministers is just getting
sick and tired of being given one line
from number 10 and going out and saying
it on the tv and defending the
government and the prime minister and
then finding out
the next day that it's not true i think
the other thing is though that many
people have supported boris johnson over
the years in the conservative party
because they believed that he was a vote
winner and we've seen from the past not
just the last two by-elections but a
couple of violations before that as well
votes slipping away from boris johnson
and i think that is another
very significant reason why he's lost so
much support within the conservative
party
electoral midas touch has been called
liz yeah please absolutely
so what we have heard just in the last
few minutes is nadim zahawi the
chancellor he was only appointed
chancellor of course yesterday we did
hear earlier that he had gone into
downing street to tell
the prime minister that as part of a
delegation if you like of cabinet
ministers that he could no longer stay
on we understand this evening that he
will not be resigning
he will carry on as chancellor he says
he wants to focus on the cost of living
and cutting the tax burden and that will
be his focus from uh tonight and going
forward he will not be standing down
back to everything that's happening
today he'd gone in there to tell the
prime minister to go yes i mean he
couldn't stay honest chancellor if he
didn't have a prime minister to serve an
utterly bizarre situation to be in and
we'll be keeping an eye now on the rest
of those cabinet ministers that went in
to say exactly the same thing for prime
minister
what will they be doing now when it
comes to are they going to continue in
their cabinet post or are they going to
stand down and that's the issue henry
hill from conservative home was just
saying to me that's the thing that's the
issue to watch for this evening if
anyone else from the cabinet walks
absolutely okay liz for the timing thank
you very much indeed well let's check in
now with our chief political
correspondent john craig he's in
parliament's central lobby where john
you were saying earlier it's all gone a
bit quiet there but i bet sir okay
physically it has i see you back in our
headquarters in westminster there and uh
but i bet the whatsapp groups are
buzzing
so quiet dermot we got booted out
because both the commons and the lords
have risen now let me bring you some
breaking news and it does involve nadim
zahaway um i've just had a statement
from the prime minister's parliamentary
private secretary that is james
duddridge who is the mp for rochford and
south end east he has revealed to sky
news exclusively that tomorrow the prime
minister and the chancellor the new
chancellor will together launch a new
economic plan no doubt aimed at tackling
the cost of living crisis the prime
minister is reported to have told mps
yesterday that with a new chancellor
would be a better chance of cutting
taxes
than under rishi soon act so let me read
you an on the record quote from james
duddridge one of the prime minister's
parliamentary private secretaries the
prime minister is in buoyant mood says
mr duddridge and will fight on and will
fight on he has a 14 million mandate and
so much to do for the country
i expect him to make senior cabinet
appointments this evening and i'm
looking forward to hearing what the pm
and his fantastic chancellor nadeem
zahawi have to say tomorrow that is an
on the record statement to sky news from
the prime minister's pps obviously
speaking with the authority of boris
johnson so a number of points there he's
in a buoyant mood well he's certainly
defiant obviously he sent the cabinet
ministers telling him to quit sent them
away earlier this evening and he will
fight on remember margaret thatcher
saying we fight on we fight to win uh
one minister said to me tonight when i
was discussing what the pm had done in
downing street this evening said well
we'll see how long that holds um as for
his 14 million mandate well of course
he's referring to the general election
there so much to do for the country as
he's been saying at pmq's and in the
liaison committee today and mr dudrick
says he expects the pm to make senior
cabinet appointments this evening now
he's already filled the vacancies left
by rishi sunak and uh and sajid javid uh
mr zahawi chancellor steve barkley
health does that mean we're expecting
some other cabinet resignations tonight
possibly um and as for uh he talks about
the pm and his fantastic chancellor uh
what they have to say tomorrow i am told
it is a joint presentation of some sort
uh an event they're gonna do tomorrow on
the economy do you remember for weeks
now uh the pm's been talking about doing
something with rishi sunak and i
remember i think it was last weekend the
two of them wrote a joint article in the
sun newspaper silent sun on sunday well
mr sunax gone tomorrow a joint
announcement from the pm and his new
chancellor presumably pledges of tax
cuts and moves to tackle the cost of
living crisis
one extraordinary turnaround john thank
you very much indeed uh john craig
live from westminster there where we're
live in downing street elizabeth is here
with me now let's just reflect on that
that john was saying you were just
telling us about nadim zahawi and saying
he wanted to get on with the job and now
we're hearing that this it was going to
involve richie sunak when he was
chancellor and it was going to take
place a little later one imagined this
month but tomorrow we're going to get
this joint statement economic statement
well this is an incredible turnaround
after we spent
today we saw the prime minister
at prime minister's question time and in
front of the liaison committee so many
miserable faces on the back benches in
the house of commons we've had all of
these resignations how many is it now
39
nadim's on hallway from from everything
that we understood today was part of a
delegation of cabinet ministers that
went into number 10 and told the prime
minister you are done you need to stand
aside we need to have a tory leadership
contest and what we're hearing this
evening is he wants to continue he wants
to focus on the cost of living crisis
and we're going to have
this plan laid out a joint plan by him
and the prime minister tomorrow as if
they're getting back to business as
usual so i think what it shows is what
we heard earlier this evening from the
prime minister that he is defiant he's
going nowhere it seems like they're
putting plans in place to make sure that
that is what it looks like over the
coming days what an evening uh liz bates
thank you very much indeed and that is
the situation right now here in downey
street as we understand it as you heard
liz saying the prime minister is defiant
senior cabinet members suggested to him
that it was time to go he told them no
and tomorrow the extraordinary news
we're hearing with the new chancellor
the prime minister will be making a
joint statement on the economy perhaps
including the tax cuts so desired by
many members of his party stay with us
continuing coverage
[Music]
[Music]
you